What is up everyone? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. And tonight we're
going to talk about a topic that comes
in all the time. Who is the king of the
south? Who is the king of the north?
This question has been dividing people.
There's been all kinds of theories and
ideas, but we want to get to the truth,
the candid truth. And to be honest, I
have not done a deep dive into this. I
really don't even know the answer to
this. And I was even reading in Daniel
today to see if I could figure it out.
And you know what? It's just a mystery.
But I know someone, a good friend of
mine who has done a deep study into
this. I'm going to bring him on right
now. This is my brother Ernest Rosa. He
is from uh what is the city? What's the
state again?
>> Antlers. Antlers, Oklahoma.
>> Antlers, Oklahoma.
>> I met this brother three plus years ago.
Every time we get together, it's a
divine appointment because when we met
up at a camp meeting, I wasn't supposed
to be a speaker. I got added on. He
wasn't supposed to be a speaker. He got
added on. Another brother was there. And
every night that we were speaking, we
did not know what we were going to be
speaking on. We didn't know what each
other were speaking on, but every night
the spirit was leading and guiding and
what I talked about, he was like, "Dude,
that's going to be in my presentation
tonight." And it was amazing. And so
what happened today is crazy because I
haven't talked to Ernest in about a
year. And two nights ago, God put him on
my heart. I saw I I was thinking back to
the time when I was hanging out with him
and his family and he called me this
morning and blew my mind. And now this
is what's happening because this is what
happens when God orchestrates things.
And I really believe this is a divine
appointment. So thank you so much for
coming on, brother.
>> Amen. No, it's a pleasure, brother.
Yeah. and return. As I mentioned to you
earlier, it was a pleasure because of
course for the past two days, you came
up to my mind. I'm like, man, Mikey,
man, I haven't spoken to my brother for
a while. And then I said, well, you
know, I was going to call you yesterday,
but I I got into a lot of things. And
then, of course, today I was preparing
actually this presentation that I'm
about to give actually from my other
platform that people had actually wanted
me to to put on the uh my personal
YouTube channel, but of course, I
haven't had it up and running. So, um,
but it's just I went when I was about to
sit down. I was in my office and I was
about to sit down. Um, I said, "Well,
let me pray before I start to, you know,
modify my my slides." And there you came
back to mine. You got to, you know,
Mikey, call Mikey. So, I said, "Okay."
So, when I was done, I sat down, picked
up the phone, we just started chatting
away, and then
>> boom, you just said that you just got
back from, I guess, what, Guatemala. I
think you said something. you got back
and then you were talking about about
your ministry, you know, your YouTube
channel, and then you you invited me to
come on. I said, "Well, when do you want
me to come on?" I was like, and you was
like, "Well, can we do it today?" And I
said, "Sure." Then you said, "Well, you
got something." I said, "Well, I do, but
this might be a hot potato." And then
you said, "No, let's come. Let's go with
it." So, I said, "All right, let's do
it." Yeah. There's people that are
waiting for it. So, you know, the Lord
gave us the opportunity. So I in return
I I appreciate your platform. In other
words, for me for allow inviting me to
be part of your platform today.
>> Praise the Lord. And what's interesting
is you gave this on a Zoom and you
forgot to record it and people were
asking you, "Hey, I want to see that."
And you're like, "I forgot to record
it." So this is the first time it's been
put out there for the rest of the world
to see who weren't in that Zoom. So
that's exciting to me.
>> I've I've given this presentation many
other times um for the past couple
years. years. I'm going to say probably
about eight years. But I've never put it
on a major platform or whatever. I've
always done it, you know, in in a close,
you know, proximity of to where I was
at, my locations, and if anybody ever
wanted me to discuss on it, I did. But,
you know, of course, like you just
mentioned earlier, this is this is a a
topic that there's so many people that
are having their own, you know, views on
who's what, the identity of who's this
north, the king of the north, and who's
the king of the south. And of course,
it's a lot of division. And I'm not one
of those that want to cause division or
any more than what it is. We have enough
of that, right?
>> You know, in in the worldwide church, if
you will, Christianom as it is,
>> but um but I think it's time for us to
move forward. Um and let it, you know,
we got to we got to present it. Let the
people study for themselves. And if and
if it's something wrong, hey, let's
let's talk, let's sit down, let's
dialogue as human beings can
>> and then but you know, let's just be
open. Let's have an open mind to it.
Yes.
>> Some people don't have an open mind. you
know, they're fixed on. No, it's this
and that's it. They're not going to see
it any other way. Well, granted f I
mean, the way that I look at it, that's
never going to change with some people.
But I do I I do ask that those that are
on this platform will have an open mind
to today's um subject.
>> Amen. You got to that if you're watching
can of truth, it's because you got an
open mind because we talk about a lot of
stuff here. So that that's what the
whole slogan is about. When you look at
the about me section, it says, "Clear
your mind of all preconceived ideas and
just look at everything with open mind
because I believe that truth will
stand." You know, that's the way it is.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> So, I got your uh disclaimer here. You
want to get into it for?
>> Yeah. Well, I just want to just present
a disclaimer. You know as you can see
here the fair use notice copyright
disclaimer under section 107 of the
copyright act of 1976 allowance is made
for the fair use for such purposes of
criticism comments news reporting
teaching scholarship education and
research. So the reason why I I I place
a disclaimer so that people can know
that the only purpose of this
presentation is to do exactly what you
see noted there just draw some criticism
we have to comment on it. Um, we are
going to be bringing some news reports.
Um, and this is for teaching and
educational research purposes. That's
the only thing. We have no gain out of
this, but we just want to share what is
out there. And this is all free to the
public. Um, we're not, well, at least
I'm not gaining anything out of it.
>> So, just keep that in mind. Um, I just
want the truth to get out and of course
you do what you can what you will with
it. If you have any questions, you can
always contact me.
>> Amen.
>> Mikey, you can offer a word of prayer.
Let's do Let's do that. Let's have a
word of prayer before we begin. Is that
all right?
>> Yes, please.
>> All right. Lord, Father in heaven, we
just thank you so much for everyone who
has decided to be here when they could
be anywhere else doing any other thing.
Lord, they are seeking for truth. And we
thank you for this opportunity to use
this technology. We just ask that you
would be with it. Lord, protect us.
Protect the technology. Um, protect the
Wi-Fi, the battery, anything that could
interfere. We just ask that you would
put a hedge of protection around us
because the enemy hates the truth and
he's always going to attack us when we
when we surrender our lives to you, when
we start um working in your field and
your mission. But Lord, we ask that you
would push away the attacks of the
enemy. And we claim the promise that no
weapon formed against us shall prosper.
And Lord, I ask that you would soften
our hearts, open our minds, give us
discernment. Lord, if this is not of
you, then show it to us. If it is,
reveal it to us. We want to study
everything line upon line according to
your word alone and not traditions and
human interpretation. And we ask that
you would be with this conversation,
that you would guide and direct this
whole thing. And we ask it would be a
blessing to many in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. Thanks, brother Jenny. All right.
So, let's just start with it. We're
going to be dealing with Daniel chapter
11. That will be our main topic. Um, as
I mentioned to Mikey earlier, it will be
a part of a three to probably a fourpart
um, series that we will be presenting on
this particular platform. Um, and the
reason for that is that I want to try to
break down as much as I can. Daniel 11,
many people don't understand that Daniel
11 is a lot of history to it.
>> You know, and sometimes when I have
studied this in the past, I said, man,
Lord, why so much history? Why why why
wouldn't it be so simpler? But God has a
reason for that. And I think one out of
the many reasons that he makes it and
that it's not as easy for us he just to
dip and then pull back out is only
because um he wants us to really get
into the nitty-gritty of his word and to
study it. We need to search as we're
searching for treasure.
>> Amen.
>> And these are of the topics that he
keeps us very busy on. So Daniel 11 is
it has a lot of history. However, for
the sake of context and for the sake of
those that are probably lay persons in
terms of learning this particular um um
a particular prophecy, I'm going to try
to make it as simple as possible. I'm
not going to go into too much history
other than the points that need to be
highlighted. When we get to more the
half of the of this of the present of
tonight's presentation, you you're going
to see that I'm going to be razoring in
a little bit more as we get to the
middle and then leaning towards the the
latter part of our of our um
presentation today. Now, um the next
presentation that we will also give will
be entitled Daniel's um Daniel 11's
North and South Kings. It will be an
extra and we're going to be exploring
Revelation 11, atheism in France.
>> There are many people that believe that
it is atheism, a atheism, if you will,
and or some some other element. But
we're going to be tackling that. We're
going to give the evidence to see
whether or not it is atheism and um and
the reasons for it. And we're going to
give some data behind it. So you can go
and do your own um um search and your
exploration in terms of what are the
evidence that is found what is the
evidence that is found out there and you
can draw your own conclusions to it.
We're not trying to present this um
presentation as a matter of fact. I do
hold to the view that I'm going to
present and I'm always open to hearing
anyone else's um thoughts or theories or
opinions um concerning this um
particular topic. But as I've always
stated many places that I go, if you're
going to submit something to me or
you're going to ask me a question and
you're requesting or you're even
demanding for me to submit evidence, I'm
willing to do all that I can. But in
like manner, I ask for the same. I I I
think it's only fair that you do the
same. I have come across many people
that unfortunately that you know will
demand for me to submit my claim and the
evidence behind it but then they fail on
their end to do likewise and I don't
think it's fair.
>> So again you know I just think it's only
fair and you'll see why I say what I
say. So we'll be talking about this
particular um um topic the extra that is
and it will deal with Revelation 11 and
this is more going to deal with the
church that I'm affiliated with. So,
it's not probably all that are are going
to probably catch on to it, but but I
will advise for those to to really sit
in to hear it to view it so that you can
understand the the information that I'm
going to be given, historical
information that I'm going to be given.
So, this will be an added plus to this
series. So, just wait until we get
there. Okay. Now,
today's um subject is entitled anchor
points Daniel 11's north and south
kings. Now in dealing with Daniel 11,
what we need to understand that if when
the Bible mentions and there are words
that are submitted in the text of Daniel
chapter 11, we have to understand that
north and south mean something. Now the
only way that you and I can understand
what north and south is, you have to
look at a geographical map. That's the
only way that you and I can understand
what north and south is. But the
question is, what is the dividing line
between north and south? We'll get to
that in just a bit. Okay? So, just keep
that in mind because we're when we
hammer this point, that's how we're
going to start razoring in to to
identify the players that are to the
north and to the south of the dividing
line. Okay. Now, let's get some backdrop
and some context so we can understand
how Daniel, the book of Daniel, which is
a prophetic book, how it actually runs
together, line upon line, if you will.
>> In Daniel chapter 2, King
Nebuchadnezzar, and I know Mikey, you
you I know you understand this at least
the Daniel chapter 2 prophecy of
Nebuchadnezzar. Remember when he had a
dream?
>> Yeah. Nebuchadnezzar had a dream of a
great brick image that the head was of
fine gold, the um the chest and arms of
silver, the belly and thighs of brass,
and then you had the um legs of iron and
then the feet of iron mixed with clay.
We came to understand and just for those
that um probably have done the study and
those that have not, well, I'm just
going to be very very concise, straight
to the point because we need to get to
the to the subject of Daniel chapter 11.
In Daniel chapter 2, that head of gold
represented the kingdom of Babylon. We
come to also find out that the chessard
of silver which was which was the second
kingdom represented the kingdom of
Persia. Then the third kingdom was
understood to be the kingdom of Greece.
It was a brass kingdom bronze depending
on what version you have. It was the
embellion thighs of brass. And then you
had the fourth kingdom which was
represented by the legs and feet of iron
which is a representation of the kingdom
of Rome. And then finally, you did have
the 10 divisions of Rome, which were the
10 toes, if you will. It doesn't say
actually say 10 toes, but the toes. And
normally speaking, we all got 10 toes.
Mikey, you got 10 toes.
>> I got 10.
>> So,
>> your wife got 10 toes, too, right?
>> Some people don't, you know,
>> but we still got our toes. Okay. So, you
know, for 10 toes. Now in Daniel chapter
2, we know that Daniel describes about a
stone that was cut out without hands and
destructive image at his feet and then
destroyed the whole image. We came to
find out that the stone, the cornerstone
if you will, rock Jesus, this is a
representation of Jesus's second coming.
Okay. Now in Daniel chapter 7 that
concept of the kingdoms that you just
heard of Babylon, Meo, Persia, Greece
and Rome was also described by way of
other symbols.
Daniel had a dream in this particular
chapter in chapter in chapter 7. He had
a vision that he saw great four I mean
four great beasts that came up out of
the sea. Again, just getting straight to
the point. The first one that came up on
the from the sea was Babylon. But
Babylon handed his scepter over to
Persia just like you find in Daniel
chapter 2. When Nebuchadnezzar saw the
image, the first kingdom was Babylon.
Then the next kingdom that came up on
the scene was Meo Persia or Persia. But
eventually Persia will hand it scepter
over to the third kingdom which is
Greece. Then Greece will hand it scepter
over to pagan Rome. Now this is the
first phase of Rome. Now in Daniel
chapter 7, there was a beast with 10
horns, iron teeth, and it was horrendous
looking. We've understood that that
particular beast represented the pagan
side of Rome. And of course, the 10
horns represented the 10 divisions of
Rome. It was splintered off within his
own kingdom into 10 divisions. Okay?
Now, that's another full prophecy at
another time. If we want to discuss it,
we can also do it. So that for those
that probably have learning this for the
first time, hey Mike, if you want to
invite me, we can talk about those
prophecies and, you know, get it all,
you know, um, packed together so people
can get the whole thing, if you will,
right? Okay. So eventually pagan Rome,
if you study, if you study Daniel
chapter 7 and Daniel chapter 8, you find
that pagan Rome eventually hands it over
to papal Rome. Now when we say paple
Rome, we're talking about Catholicism,
the papacy. um it's a universal church
for the word Catholic means universal.
So it was a church within the confines
of the jurisdiction or the empire of
Rome where we knew that at one time most
specifically speaking that you know the
terminology that we tend to know more of
is the dark ages and the Roman Catholic
Church was really the ruling faction at
the time. They co-joined with the kings
and at that time the kings were
subjected to the demands of the church.
So the church was actually ruling the
state. There are people that are trying
to say it reverse that the state was
ruling the church. No, when you really
look at history, you will find that the
church was the one that was actually
pushing the buttons. Now that was Paper
Rome. But you come to find out in Daniel
chapter 7, Paper Rome would eventually
hand the scepter over forcibly, not that
not willingly granted to the future
king, Jesus himself. Now that's all
covered in Daniel 7 2 and 7. However,
now we're getting to chapter 11. Now,
let me break down to you the concept of
Daniel chap 11. In Daniel 11, we have to
understand the prelude, the chapter
itself, and the conclusion.
Let me repeat that again. The prelude,
the chapter itself, and then the
conclusion. No. So, what is the prelude?
prelude to to to the who's the
identification of the kings of the north
and the kings of the south comes in
Daniel chapter 10. So in order to
understand Daniel chapter 10, you really
got to understand Daniel chapter 2, 7
more so chapter 8 and chapter nine and
then you get into chapter 10. Chapter 10
is the prelude. Chapter 11 is the story
line if you will, the chapter itself.
And then chapter 12 is the conclusion.
Okay? That's where it closes up. So
those three main chapters, chapter 10,
chapter 11, and chapter 12 are the main
ones that you must study, must keep
joined together because they're all one
storyline, if you will. All right. Now,
in Daniel 10 and 11 and 14, I'm going to
be as simplistic as possible to get to
the main point. Okay. Now, Mikey, if I'm
if I'm if I if when you're when you're
hearing this and you feel like I'm not
being clear about something, just stop
me and I'll do my best to try to clarify
if that's okay.
>> Yeah. I mean, it so far everything's
clear clear to me cuz I've studied some
of this, but I I think you're making it
pretty solid.
>> Okay. All right. So, in Daniel chapter
10, the angel Gabriel appears to um to
Daniel. And and again, very concise. I'm
not going to I'm not trying to be
exhaustive. I'm going to hit anchor
points, okay? I'm not going to go into
too much history, at least not in the
beginning half.
Gabriel tells Daniel or he comes to
Daniel and and as the Bible reads here
and behold and hand touched me which set
me upon my knees and he said unto me,
this is Gabriel speaking to Daniel. Oh
Daniel, a man greatly beloved,
understand the words that I speak unto
thee.
Now I am come to make thee understand
what shall befall. And I want you to
notice Mikey,
>> it says there, thy people in what? In
the what?
>> In the in the latter days. Okay. So I
want you to understand what's another
terminology that we tend to use in
connection or meaning latter days. What
that's another word that we might use
>> the end times last days.
>> The last days or the following days,
right? Meaning more futuristic as
opposed to just immediately. Right?
Okay. So I want you to notice it says
what shall befall upon thy people in the
latter days. Now that's very key to
understand the last part of Daniel
chapter 10. Okay? Because you have to
ask the question, who are Daniel's
people in the last days? Now, you rec
you can recall when you look at Daniel,
his people at the time are the
Israelites. Would you agree? The
Hebrews.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. The Jews, right? Okay. So, now,
but the Bible says here that Gabriel
tells him that I'm going to help you to
understand what's going to happen to
your people in the last days. Now, who
are Daniel's people in the last days?
The best way we can understand as going
to the book of Galatians by the pen of
the apostle Paul when he writes the
epistle to the Galatians and he says as
follows. For as many as you as have been
baptized into Christ have put on Christ.
There is neither Jew nor Greek. There is
neither bond nor free. There is neither
male nor female. For ye are all one in
Christ Jesus. And if ye be Christ's then
ye are what?
>> Abraham's seed.
>> Abraham's seeds. heir according to the
promise. So, is this suggesting that we
don't have to be from we don't have to
have Jewish blood within our veins to
become part of Abraham's seed?
>> Absolutely.
>> Absolutely. Right. Now, look at this
other text found in Romans. The Apostle
Paul writing this letter as well. For he
is not a Jew which is out one outwardly,
neither is that circumcision which is
outward in the flesh, but he is a Jew
which is one inwardly. And circumcision
is that of the heart. Amen.
>> I want you to notice. That's that's a
true circumcision in the spirit and not
in the letter whose praise is not of men
but of God. So Mikey, I think you
understand what he's suggesting. We
don't have to be a literal Jew, meaning
bloodline, the seed of Abraham to be
grafted in, if you will. We can get more
text, but again, for the sake of time, I
think these two texts will should
suffice. Now, we know the Bible said,
"For out of the mouth of two or three
witnesses, let every word be
established." So, we're establishing
that point. Now, let's get to Daniel
chapter 11. We're rolling into d and I'm
just going to go to this text. Now, if
you notice, it's Daniel 11:11. I'm kind
of fast forwarding, but I'm going to
pull back the curtain, but I want to get
some context to understand south and
north. Now, the Bible says here, "And
the king of the south shall be moved
with colar, that is anger." And I'm
using the King James version. And shall
come forth and fight with him even with
the king of the north. And he shall set
forth a great multitude, but the
multitude shall be given into his hands.
Now question. So who are these kings of
of the north and the kings of the south?
That's what we need to identify. Again,
just anchor points. The key to
understand, however, Mikey um Daniel 11
is found in what book? As you see in
your screen?
>> Wait, where was it? In Jeremiah.
in the Jeremiah. Now, the reason why
we're saying that is because remember
when you read, we don't I'm not going to
put up on the screen, but if anybody can
read Daniel, we just have to ask who was
Daniel's prophet at his time.
>> The prophet to Daniel was actually
Jeremiah. You read Daniel chapter 9,
he's literally studying the book of
Jeremiah. So Jeremiah was the one that
went before him. The books were written.
He was studying and he was understanding
if you read Daniel chapter 9 the time
period that now they were about to be
released to go back to their homeland.
Okay, about the 70 years of captivity.
He was studying that passage in
Jeremiah. So obviously Daniel was
studying the book of Jeremiah. Now catch
this. If you go to Jeremiah 1 13 and 15,
the Bible says, "And the word of the
Lord came unto me the second time
saying, "What seeest thou?" And I said,
I see a seathing spot, and the face
thereof is toward the north. I want you
to notice the compass direction that
he's that he's on writing down. Then the
Lord said unto me, out of the what?
>> North,
>> out of the north. What's going to come
out of the north?
>> Evil.
>> Evil shall break up forth upon all the
inhabitants of the land. I want you to
notice he gives us a direction that
something bad is going to happen. Am I
right with that?
>> Yeah.
>> Now, check this out. For low, I will
call the
>> families of the kingdoms of the Lord.
>> Is that singular or is that plural?
>> That's plural.
>> It's plural. So that means it's more
than one. Is that not right?
>> Yep. It even says call all the families.
>> And then what? Continue to read it.
>> Of the kingdoms.
>> Continue to read the yellow highlight.
>> The families of the kingdoms of the
north.
>> Okay. So you notice it says kingdom. So
it's going to be multiple kingdoms. Am I
right with that?
>> Correct.
Okay, sayeth the Lord, and they shall
come and they shall set everyone his
throne at the entering of the gates of
Jerusalem and against all the walls
thereof round about and against all the
cities of Judah. So obviously remember
according to the previous text, evil was
going to come from the what direction
again? Um
>> the north,
>> Mikey.
>> Okay. And it's going to come towards
what specific city?
>> Jerusalem.
>> Jerusalem, right? That's what the Bible
is actually telling us. Now, we know
that Babylon
conquered Jerusalem, right? We obviously
know that because Jeremiah explains that
to us. But I want you to look at the at
the map. You notice that Babylon,
ancient Babylon, which is modern day Ira
Iraq today. Okay? But ancient Babylon,
in order to get to Jer um to Jerusalem,
when you look at the map, did they did
they go straight across or how do you
how do you analyze that particular map?
>> Wait, what do you mean go straight
across?
>> Did they go in order? Okay. Jerusalem is
to the left. You see that black arrow,
right?
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Okay. Jerusalem is to the left and
Babylon's to the right. So did they the
Babylon the forces of Babylon did they
did they just go straight AC across
>> no
>> that area or did they did it appear that
they went north and descended from the
north to the south
>> right if I'm looking at that highlighted
red yeah they had to go up and then down
>> okay the reason for that brother Mikey
is because between when you see that
that that sha that area not the shaded
area that's in red but more the golden
area there was a full desert there
between the two of cities.
>> Now if they would have taken their
follow or rather if Babylon would have
taken their soldiers through that
desert, it would have been mass suicide.
>> Right?
>> So what they had to do was climb up and
then descend from what direction?
>> The north.
>> From the north. Remember the text that
the families of the kingdom of the north
and evil was about to come from them.
Now are you getting this?
>> Yep.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So now
>> according to Jere Jeremiah as well as
our previous prophecies, Babylon would
also fall victim to being conquered by
another king coming in from the north.
What would be that next kingdom? Well,
the Bible actually predicted it. For lo,
I will raise and cause to come up
against Babylon.
>> Now you notice Babylon was used by God
to to spank, if you will, Jerusalem for
their um rebellion towards God. We know,
you can read it all throughout the book
of Jeremiah. You see what happened
during the time during the um period of
um King Zedekiah. He failed to heed the
council of Jeremiah and therefore
Nebuchadnezzar came in. You can read all
about it. Okay. But here according to
the text Jeremiah actually says then one
day
>> God was going to spank the kingdom of
Babylon as well.
>> It it reads as follows. And law raising
calls to come up against Babylon and
assembly of great nations from the what?
What country?
>> The north country. The you notice you
notice the directions that God is lining
out, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So against Babylon, something is also
going to come from what direction again?
The north.
>> And they shall set themselves in array
against her. From hence from then shall
be sh she shall be taken. Their arrow
shall be asked of a mighty expert man.
None shall return in vain. And if you go
to Isaiah 13, it specifically names the
the kingdom that's going to do such a
thing against Babylon. The Bible, and
brother Jenny, if you'll be kind enough,
go ahead and read that text.
>> Yeah. Behold, I will stir up the messes
against them, which shall not regard
silver as and as for gold, they shall
not delight in it. Their bows also shall
dash the young men in or to pieces and
they shall have no pity on the fruit of
the womb. Their eye shall not spare
children. And Babylon, the glory of
kingdoms, the beauty of the cow chaldes
excellency shall be as when God
overthrew Sodom and Gomorrah.
>> So he's equal. I mean, he's he's
equating the overthrow of Babylon to
what? Two major cities.
>> Uh, Mes and Caldes.
>> No, no, no. At the at the latter part of
that verse,
>> the bottom all the way in the bottom.
What two cities?
>> Oh, Sodom and Gomorra.
>> Exactly. So, you know that Sodom and
Gomorrah was overthrown, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, God was going to do the same thing
to the mighty empire of Babylon. We know
that because when you get to Daniel
chapter 5, you find what h what happened
with Belshazzar and remember the writing
on the wall.
>> Yeah.
>> That was the time period that this is
referring to. Okay. So now we know that
Babylon was the first kingdom that was
on the scene that came up on the scene
in Daniel 2, Daniel 7. And then now
we're just for forgetting context. We
can understand that that was a a nation
that was going to come in from the
direction of the north. Now the me of
Persian we have also came understood
that they will come in from the north.
We just read it.
>> Okay. Now in Daniel 11:2 this one we're
going to start from the top. I want you
to notice the Bible says behold there
shall stand up in Persia. I want you to
notice the highlighted word in red or
pink. Stand up. We got to identify that
word first. Many people overlook that.
This clause is very important for us to
understand every other verse that has
the same clause in it. Now the term
stand up simply refers to another king
taking up the kingship. Let me repeat
that again.
>> Every time you see the term stand up,
that means another king stands up or
takes the kingship or takes the throne.
It could be a king within that kingdom
or another rising kingdom or another
rising king from another rather another
king from another rising kingdom. Are
you understanding what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> In Daniel chapter 2, it gives us a
little bit more detail about the kingdom
of Persia. Now, check this out. It says
here, "Behold, there shall stand up yet
three kings in Persia, and the fourth
shall be far richer than they all."
>> Now, we got to understand something. It
says the fourth. Well, in order to
understand who was this fourth that was
far richer than it all, we have to
identify who were the first three. Well,
the first three beginning with number
one was Kambbias II, which was King
Cyrus's son. Remember, he was the
Persian um the Persian guard or the the
warrior um that came into um that took
over um Babylon.
>> And we you heard of the Cyrus cylinder.
Well, this is his son Kambbias the
second. Then you had smurdis baria. He
was an imposttor. He didn't last too
long in office. And then you had the
rise the first. Then you had the fourth
which was Xerxes which is also named in
other parts of your Bible called or in
the in in the story of Esther King
Ahazerus. So Xerxes the first and King
Ahazerus are the same person. This is
Esther's husband. Esther's huben. Okay.
>> This is the one that that that verse is
referring to. So now we come to anchor
point number one. Daniel 11:2A deals
with what kingdom? What do you see
there, Mikey?
>> Persia.
>> Persia. So that's what that's the that's
the first anchor point. Oh, and by the
way, let me pause here. Daniel chapter 2
and Daniel chapter 7 deals with Babylon,
Meo, Persia, Greece, and then Rome.
However, in Daniel chapter 8 onward to
the rest of the book of Daniel, till you
close it out, Babylon is shifted out of
the scene. And anytime that you see the
prophecy in Daniel chapter 8 or in
Daniel chapter 11, it starts off with
Meo Persia, then Greece, and then Rome.
Other people would try to say something
else, but we'll get to that. So I want
you to understand Daniel chapter 2 as
parallel as it parallels with Daniel
chapter 8. The first entity on the scene
is the kingdom of the me and the
Persians. Okay. Now 2A is the only time
that is more specifically talking about
Persia.
>> Okay. Now the Bible goes on to say in 2B
I want you to notice the well let's read
it all together. It says here, "Behold,
there shall stand up yet three kings in
Persia, and the fourth shall be far
richer than they all, and by his
strength, through his riches, he shall
stir up all against the realm of
Greece." Now, that's a very interesting
um text. What that is saying, um,
brother Jenny, is that Esther's husband,
Ahazerus, was the more he was the he was
he was he was the king that was far
richer than any of his predecessors.
and he was the one to inflict a blow
upon Greece that literally made Greece
very very volatile, if you will, toward
Persia. Now, when we're talking about
this king um um Hazerus or Xerxes, we're
not talking about the latter part of
Persia because that came in the future.
Persia is still the ruling faction of
the time, but it agitated something
within the realm of the kingdom of
Greece. Now I want you to understand
something.
In these days of aaz hazarus or Xerxes
the first, the Bible says in Ezra
chapter 1 verse 1 and 4, in the days of
Ahazareus, he showed his what? The
riches of his glory
>> just like you find here far richer than
they are. Are you understanding this so
far, brother Jenny?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I'm trying to take it very slow so
we can get some context. Okay. Now, we
need to So, from from this point on, all
right. Well, we this is I'm going to try
to illustrate as best as I can. In
Daniel chapter 11, it does something a
little bit different to the previous
three chapters. Daniel chapter 2, Daniel
chapter 7, and Daniel chapter 8. What
this chapter does is that it throws up
the the the next coming kingdom, but it
pulls back the curtain a little bit
further back into the history of the of
its predecessor. And then it tells us
that this other kingdom is about to
emerge. But it doesn't actually take the
baton if you will or it takes the full
scepter yet. But it just tells you that
something is about to come and then when
that next kingdom comes up on the scene,
the previous kingdom is never discussed
about again. Let me make an let let me
bring an example. So at this time in
Daniel 11:2, the current reigning or
champ or king or kingdom was Persia. We
took care of that. Remember that it was
Persia. Now what we find in 2B, we find
that another rising kingdom is about to
emerge. That kingdom is Greece. The
Bible specifically said it was Greece.
From this point on, even though that the
kingdom of Persia is still the reigning
champ and there's still more history to
it as being the ruling faction of the
time, Daniel 11 doesn't care about the
previous kingdom when a new kingdom is
now touched on. From that point on, the
previous kingdom is never discussed
about. And then the current kingdom is
what's going to be the focus on until
the next rising power comes on the
scene. Did I make myself clear? I know
that was a drawn out explanation. Okay,
you're getting the point, right?
>> Yeah, the illustrations really help.
>> Okay, so let's look at another um
example dealing with the term stand out.
That's another again, we have to
understand this concept because Daniel
11 is very difficult for many people
just to grab, you know, wrap their minds
around. So if they can get the simplest
terms understood, then the Lord can
really unlock a lot of things to them.
Okay. So now in Daniel 11:3, now
remember 2 A I 2 A dealt with Daniel
11:2A dealt with the first part dealt
with the kingdom of um Gre um sorry
Persia. Daniel 11:2 brings in Greece.
Now in Daniel 11:3, that was 2B. Daniel
11:3 says the following. and a mighty
king shall stand up that shall rule with
great dominion and do according to his
will. Remember the term stand up. Okay,
that term stand up remember uh if you
recall represents the fact that another
king will take the throne. It could be
within its own kingdom or the rising
power that will come and take the
scepter. In this case, that verse is
specifically talking about Alexander the
Great himself.
>> Okay,
>> remember he was 33. He was 30. I think
he died at the age of 32, one month shy
of being 33. And he actually died in the
kingdom of Babylon. He remember he had
that jurisdiction as well. So Greece is
now the ruling faction of the time.
You're never going to hear about Persia
again. Okay. As you can see on your
screen, you have Greece. Now Jenny, how
do you see where do you see that arrow
coming from? From the south or is it
coming from the north?
>> From the north.
>> Coming from the north. Remember the the
families from the kingdoms of the north.
Evil was always going to be fall.
Remember
um um the angel Gabriel told Daniel, I'm
going to explain to you what's going to
fall upon your people in the latter
days. Remember that? So God's people get
caught up in the middle, if you will.
>> Okay. Now
the NIV ver let me see okay the NIV
version says the following this is verse
four okay and now I just you I don't
typically use an NIV version but for the
sake of simplicity I think that this
version in this particular verse helps
to helps us to understand the context of
verse four he appeared his empire shall
be broken up and parcled parcelled out
toward the four winds of heaven it will
not go to his descendants nor will it
have the power he exercised because his
empire will be uprooted and given to
others.
>> This is none other than the one faction
that we found in Daniel chapter 2 and
Daniel chapter 7. So who were these
others? These others that were that the
gender was given over to was his four
generals. One was Cassander, the other
one was Lysmicus, the third one was
Salucas and then the fourth one was
Tammy. Now Cassander took the
jurisdiction of Macedonia. Lysmicus took
Thrace northeast and northeast major
minor. Salucas took Syria and Babylon
that jurisdiction. And then Talamy took
north of Africa which more specifically
he identified with the the the landmark
of um of Egypt.
Those were the four generals. Remember
the text says here um uh u Mikey the
four that it was parcelled out to the
four winds of heaven. Mhm.
>> Okay. And then of course we identify who
are these four. It was just that. Now
in Daniel 5 through8, now we're going to
get some context to what's happening
within the kingdom of Greece. The Bible
goes on to say, "And the kingdom and the
king of the south shall be strong and
one of his princes, and he shall be
strong above him and have dominion. His
dominion shall be a great dominion,
and in the end of years they shall join
themselves together. For the king's
daughter of the south shall come to the
king of the north. I want you to notice,
the king's daughter of the south shall
come against the kingdom of north
to make an agreement. But she shall not
retain the power of the arm. Neither
shall shall shall he stand, nor his arm,
but she shall be given up. and they
shall be they shall they that brought
her and he that begat her and he that
strengtheth her in these times. And then
it finally says, "But out of the branch
of her roots shall one stand up." I want
you to notice stand up in his estate
which shall come with an army and shall
enter into the fortresses of the king of
the north and shall deal against them
and shall prevail and shall also carry
captives into what location you what's.
the specific location it gives us here
>> in the Egypt.
>> Egypt. Don't never forget that location.
>> All right,
>> it says Egypt their gods and with their
princess and with their precious vessels
of silvering and of gold and he shall
continue more years than the king in the
north. Now again, as I me stated earlier
when we're reading this, we're probably
we're breaking our said, what in the
world is verses 5 and 8 talking about?
We're not going to get into the
specifics of everything here because
that'll be another study. We can
identify the players here. But just to
stay on track to get to the latter part
of Daniel 11, which a lot of people
really want to know with more what's
going to happen in the latter end,
>> one thing that we have to draw from
these ver verses, what's a specific
location that is given us? And you
notice what it's given us? It is Egypt.
>> Egypt.
>> Never forget that. Okay. So now
what you have here when you look at this
particular screen there are four
generals. You have Cassandra, Lysmicus,
Salucid, I mean the um the Salucas and
then Talamy. Now I said Salucas of
Seucids but that was the Seucid dynasty.
What Daniel focuses on now is the Seucid
dynasty and the Tammy dynasty. Cassander
and Lysmicus are never discussed about
any longer. So verse three, verse four
had to deal with them. But now from this
point on, what you just read from verses
5 through8, I believe it was
specifically talking about the Seus to
the north and the talmies to the south
>> within the jurisdiction or the kingdom
of Greece. Okay. Now, if you look at the
at at your map, what you find here is
the Seolucits to the north, the shaded
area, the red the big shaded um red
shaded area. That's the Seucid Kingdom,
Kingdom of Greece, and then you had
Tomies. Now, remember um um Mikey, when
you read Daniel 7, remember the
four-headed leper?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. Remember that there were four
kings. You had Talamies, Salucas, um,
Lysmicus and Cassander. There was a
massive civil war that broke out.
Everyone fighting for the throne. So, it
was split four different ways. What
Daniel 11 is does is just focus on the
latter two. Cassander and Lysmicus is
not ever discussed. This is going to be
our main point because there's something
that's caught in the middle. What do you
see on your screen that's caught? Who's
caught in the middle?
>> Jerusalem.
But it but what do you what do you see
there underneath Jerusalem?
>> Yeah. God's people.
>> God's people. Okay. So remember God told
Daniel by way by through the channel of
using the angel Gabriel that something
was going to happen to God's people in
the last days. Now remember for Daniel
to understand this he has to be looking
at a map. Are you understanding what I'm
saying? Because he has to know what's
north and south.
>> Right?
This is where a lot of people are
missing the point just with that alone.
>> Yeah.
>> So in vision, he's understanding, okay,
north here, south here. What's the
dividing line? Dividing line is God's
people. Yeah.
>> Okay. That's your dividing line.
>> So when you look at the map there, north
is to the north, south is to the south.
That simple.
>> And I'll tell you before I even heard
any of this, when I was thinking in my
mind, what what is north? North from
where? I was thinking it's got to be
Jerusalem because that's where I don't
know. It seems like everything in the
Bible that's the focus point
>> and I've heard that language the the way
language is read is like always goes
towards Jerusalem
random fact but
>> correct but you notice though what I did
though in Daniel chapter 10 we we now
it's made clear
when when Gabriel speaks to Daniel he
sets him up he said listen I'm just
going to let you know what's going to
happen to your people then he draws out
a map in vision and he said this is
north this is south Daniel obviously
where's your people oh it's in the
middle okay boom now you know what's
north and now you know what's south
let's move forward are you understanding
this
>> okay that's what he's telling okay so
now according to the prophecy
would the Grecian Empire last forever
well if we take in consideration to what
we just discussed earlier Daniel chapter
2 Daniel chapter 7 obviously he's not
going to be the ruling faction until the
end of time we know that eventually
Greece handed his scepter over to
another power. Now, we go, we're
springboarding all the way to verse 14
and 16. I want you to notice, "And in
those times there shall many stand up
against the king of the south." So,
another power is coming. Remember the
term stand up refers to the taking up of
a kingship, taking up of the throne.
>> So, something is about to happen again.
And then when you read when you read
verse 16, it's going to give us a little
bit more context. So we already
uncovered that the first anchor point of
112 was Persia A. Um 11B
all the way to 11 I mean 1116A
the first one. I say A is the first part
of um of verse 16 is referring to the
kingdom of Greece. Now we're going to
understand which is the next power. In
verse 16 it helps us to understand
something. But he that cometh against
him shall do according to his own will,
and none shall stand before him. And he
Okay, now let me pause here because
there's something else that I failed to
mention. The one that is highlighted in
red,
that refers to the king of the north.
And then the one that you see
highlighted in blue,
that's the one is referring to the king
of the south.
>> But I want you to notice, remember,
we're talking about the the kingdom of
Greece, but something's about to come
from the north. And it says here,
um, "And none shall stand before him,
and he, the king of the north, shall
stand in the glorious land." Now Mikey,
what do you think? The glorious land,
what land do you think that's referring
to?
>> Is it Jerusalem?
>> Jerusalem, brother. That's how simple it
is.
>> Yeah, that's the promised land.
>> Exactly.
>> It's the promised land.
>> So, it's telling us that a king is going
to stand up in that area. M okay. So
it's Jerusalem which is called the
glorious land which by his hand shall be
consumed. Now the glorious land as you
can see on the map is Jerusalem. Simple
as that. Now from this point on we're
going to I'm going to kind of highspeed
it. But um or hight tail as they say.
But what I'm going to do is is that now
we're going to understand some of the
other players that are going to come on
the scene. Okay. So now check this out.
Rome in verse 16 is now being projected
as now starting to take the baton or
take the scepter. But I want but you
know as well as I do when you study
prophecy Rome had two phases. The first
phase was what you see on your screen
that is pagan Rome. Pagan Rome come
comes up on the scene. Now in Daniel
11:20, it gives us a major clue to
understand who's the player or what
faction is actually the which is the
ruling faction of the time the Bible.
And Mikey, go ahead and read that one.
>> Then shall stand up in his estate a
razor of taxes in the glory of the
kingdom, but within few days he shall be
destroyed, neither in anger nor in
battle.
>> Okay. So let's focus on the on the on
the beginning part of that text. It says
here stand up. So what does stand up
again imply?
>> It means uh taking rulership.
>> Okay. But who takes rulership according
to the text? It says here in his estate
a razor of taxes. Does that ring a bell?
Um
um brother Mikey razor of taxes.
>> Raiseor taxes.
>> Think about New Testament time.
>> Think about who?
New Testament time.
>> New Testament time.
>> Let me try to help you out.
>> Caesar.
>> Very good. Okay. So, we know that it's a
king that stands up. Okay. Now, does the
Bible ever mention of a mighty empire
that issue taxes?
>> Mhm.
>> You just said it.
>> Caesar that which is Caesars's.
>> No. Listen, read that text. Remember
this story.
>> Yeah. Uh, and it came to pass in those
days that there went out a decree from
Caesar Augustus that all the world
should be taxed.
>> I think we found a link.
>> Yeah.
>> So we we know according according to
this text that Rome now is the ruling
faction now. So that would mean from
this point on you would never hear about
Greece any longer.
>> Wow, dude.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Yes.
>> Are you getting it?
>> Yeah, man.
>> Okay. It's Greece, Meo Persia will never
be discussed again. Now, the first phase
of Rome, remember it's pagan Rome. Okay,
pagan Rome. Now, well, let me go back.
Let me go back because I think I need to
go back to this text. It says here,
"Then shall stand up in his estate a
razor of taxes in the glory of the
kingdom." Remember, the glorious kingdom
>> Jerusalem
>> is Jerusalem. Okay? So this is the
context of the scripture because the
focus is about God's people which will
lead into the last days. Now let me fast
forward. Okay. So we're talking about
Roman kingdom. Now we're going to jump
forward two verses. Again we're just
trying to get to to the main point. Next
time that we we we talk or one in our
future studies we'll get more into the
nitty-gritty of the players specifically
with the preceding verses. I just want
to get to the main points. Okay. Now,
Daniel 11:22.
Now, we started in Daniel 10. Then we
got to Daniel 11:2. Now, we're all the
way to verse 22. And in Daniel 11, it
goes all the way to verse 45. All right.
It says here, "And with his arm," this
is remember pagan Rome.
And with the arms of a flood shall be
shall they be overflown from before him,
and shall be broken. Yay. Also, the
prince of the covenant. M
>> prince of the covenant.
>> Who is this prince of the covenant? Just
take a take a stab you just take a stab
at it.
>> Jesus Christ.
>> Who do you think the
>> brother? There's none other than Jesus
the Lord.
>> That's right.
>> So, we're talking about pagan Rome, the
time period of Jesus now. But this is a
in-n-out ordeal. This verse is an
in-n-out ordeal. Okay? I want you to
notice the latter part of that verse.
It says here and with the arms of a
flood they shall be overflow overflown
from before him and shall be broken. Yay
also the prince of the covenant. So that
means the prince of the covenant was
going to be broken. So was the prince of
a covenant ever destroyed?
>> The prince of covenant. Oh yeah.
>> If you're saying that
>> Okay. When
>> at his crucifixion
>> is crucifixion. Very good. Now, this is
where you need to tie it into Daniel
chapter nine. In Daniel chapter 9, it
says, "The Messiah, the prince shall be
cut off." What does it imply when it
says cut off? He was killed. Right.
>> Yep.
>> Exactly. Now, remember, this is one
thing that we got to keep in mind. Is
Jesus a king?
>> Yeah. King of kings. Well, we can say he
would be, you know, he came as a to be
more specific, he came as a sacrifice,
but we know that he's our future king.
Right.
>> Right.
>> But keep this in mind that when he jumps
up on the scene, something is going to
happen with Christianity.
See, in Daniel chapter 7, we talk about
the 70we prophecy. This is something
you're familiar with. Remember the 70
weeks?
>> Yeah.
>> Or there was 490 years. remember that
he'd have 483 years for um the decree
that um that Artis Xerx I'm sorry um not
Artic Xerxes
>> what was his name of for the life of me
>> I thought it was
>> Was it Artic Xerxes?
>> I thought so.
>> No, hold on a sec. I for the life of me
I'm just trying to think of um the
person. No, I just don't want to um
misquote it. Um
it's not Art Xerxes. It is. Is it
articles?
>> Lord, help me. Help me.
>> No, no, no, no, no.
>> Yes, I was right. Artic Xerx.
>> So, you had me second guessing, man.
>> Okay. Yeah, Artic Xerxes. I'm thinking
I'm thinking of a Hazerus. I'm sorry.
I'm thinking of a Hazerus. Xerxes
himself. Okay. This is not the same one
here. But this Xerx this out of Xerxes,
the king is the one that issues the
decree. Forgive me people that are
watching. It is that one. Artis Xerxes.
You were right Mikey. Okay. Artic
Xerxes. He is the one that gives the
decree that now catapulted the pro
prophecy to come into action. And for
483 years, it led all the way to the
baptism of Jesus. And then three and a
half years later, he was crucified. And
three and a half years later, the gospel
goes to the world. You can read it in
Acts chapter 7, I mean Acts chapter 6,
when when it when when Steven is taken
into the tribunal. Remember that? that
he's taken into court, if you will, to
the Jewish courts.
>> And um he is now interrogated
>> and then he gives a law a covenant
lawsuit and then he he he you know he's
basically um blaming the Jews for for
them killing Jesus and then afterwards
you know that he's taken outside
>> and then he's stoned and then chapter 8
what happens because of persecution
within on Jerusalem they are scattered
abroad preaching preaching to all these
other nations. So this is what happened
within the 70 weeks. And remember the
Bible makes it makes it very clear when
you read Daniel chapter 9 verse 24. 70
weeks are determined upon thy people and
upon thy holy city to um finish the
transgression. It lists of seven issues
that was supposed to take place in
Jerusalem. And if they did not meet that
criteria, God was about to cut them off
as the depositories of his law in order
to be the beacon light to the world. And
then he was going to use anybody anybody
that was willing. whosoever will, let
him come to take this message to the
world. So he wasn't doing away with
Jews, but he was not going to use him as
a nation to teach the world. Does that
does that make sense?
>> Yeah. Before you leave this slide, if
you're if you're done,
>> I just want to cover something because
we've never actually covered this 70
weeks prophecy. And it's it's so vital
because I was raised in churches that
taught that there's a 7-year tribulation
that's coming. They they first of all,
they teach that there's a
pre-tribulation rapture. We've discussed
that many times on this channel that the
the rapture is the second coming, but
there is no seven years of tribulation.
I I challenge anyone look throughout the
Bible. I've I've asked people and
they're like, "Yeah, it's in
Revelation." It's not. It comes from
Daniel. It's a misinterpretation of
Daniel. And it's it's crazy because this
is a prophecy right here. And Daniel, I
mean, look at far back before Jesus came
to earth that Daniel predicted
everything about Christ and he fulfilled
it perfectly. And yet people will take
Daniel 9:27 and say that it's about the
antichrist. Like literally they take a
prophecy about Jesus and say it's the
antichrist. And what it what it is is it
says, "And he shall confirm a covenant
with many for one week." Who was the one
that we're in the new covenant, right?
Who was the one that confirmed the
covenant? That's Jesus. And we just got
through reading that. And it says, "And
in the midst of the week,
he shall he shall cause the sacrifice
and oblation to cease." Who caused the
sacrificial system to cease? Jesus
Christ.
and for an overspreading of abominations
and he shall make it desolate even until
the consummation. But the verse right
before it is the confusing part where it
says um after three score and two weeks
shall Messiah be cut off. That's clear.
Who is that? Messiah cut off. That's
Jesus. Not for himself and the people of
the prince and they shall come and
destroy the city and all this stuff. So,
it's so crazy that this prophecy could
convince any person that Jesus Christ is
the Christ because he fulfilled
something that he could have never
planned. He can't plan when he's going
to be born. He can't plan when he's
going to be baptized. He can't plan when
he's going to be crucified.
And he fulfilled the prophecy perfectly.
And yet, most denominations, most
mainline Christianity will look at this
prophecy and say, "That's the
Antichrist."
Blows my mind, dude.
That's right. And it's very good good
point. As a matter of fact, if you want
to, brother, we can tackle this
particular prophecy in connection to the
point that you're bringing on that
people are believing in the in the
seven-year tribulation. This is one
study that we to give to people because
many people, if you can't explain Daniel
chapter 9, you can make Daniel chapter
9, make it mean anything else. And
that's the reason why people believe in
the lie as instead of the truth because
they've never studied it. So whenever I
go to give presentations and people ask
me about this prophecy, when we break it
down from A to Z, brother, it blows
their mind.
>> Amen.
>> And this is when we show and this is
what I say. I said, well, they'll say
seven semi-week tribulation.
I'll ask them, give me the text that
says seven week tributar,
I'm sorry, I said sevenyear tribulation.
>> They can't find it.
>> Yeah,
>> they can't find it. They'll say Daniel
chapter 9, but I said, 'Okay, you have
seven years, but where? Find the word
tribulation.
>> They said, 'Well, I said, and they'll
say, 'Well, it's in Matthew chapter 24.
I said, yeah, let's go to Matthew 24.
Tribulation. I said, but find me where
it says seven years. Can't find the link
there.
>> What we actually
>> go ahead. Well, well, what we actually
see is that there's going to be much
tribulation like birth panges that are
more intense and more frequent until
Christ says, "I must return or else no
flesh will be saved." There's no actual
time period of like, "Well, today is the
beginning of tribulation." No, we are
living through tribulation. It's getting
worse and worse and worse until it's
going to be
>> so bad. I mean, we're we're there. I
mean, there is the world is in utter
chaos right now, primed and ready to
receive the Antichrist.
>> And uh but it's so important to
understand prophecy because if if you're
looking for a seven-year tribulation,
you're going to be so lost. You're going
to be derailed.
>> I know. And this is one of those times,
Mikey, that we need to really be
studying. I mean, studying hard
>> because the devil's going to come. It's
going to sift everybody that he can. And
the reason why he's going to do that is
because we're so glued to the
television, we're glued to our phones.
And he's allowing us to hear. Now, I
believe that our phones, our phones, our
phones is the knowledge of good and
evil.
>> It's a tree of the knowledge of good and
evil. A lot of good, but there's a lot
more bad in it.
>> Amen.
>> If we're not careful, even things that
we deem that are
>> that are that is good, if it gets our
mind off of Christ, it could be our God.
>> Yep.
>> And we don't think of these type of
things. So this is where we right now
with everything that's taking place
today. I mean prophecy is fulfilling. I
mean it's just it's just listen there's
non-stop. It's like it's like a a
runaway locomotive as they say. It's
there not there's no stopping it.
There's no stopping it. Jesus is about
to come.
>> Amen.
>> And this is why I I go back to this this
presentation. We need to understand this
presentation because I believe that God
has given us another added clue to
understand what's taking place in the
last days so that we can say we're
there. We are literally there. Make no
mistake about it.
>> Amen.
>> Make no mistake about it. But thank you
um brother Mikey because this that
that's a very good point and again like
I say we I have a study on that on that
alone because this is in connection to
the 2300 day prophecy.
>> Okay, of Daniel chapter 8.
>> So and then we and what I do is I'll
link up the two chapters together and
you will see that one chapter does
actually go with the next chapter.
>> We can break that down. We can do that.
you tell me when if you want to do that
we can revisit that point and then uh we
can um share that on your on your
platform if you would like.
>> Sounds great bro.
>> Okay. So let's move forward. Okay. So
now what you have here because Jesus
died on the cross remember you have
paganism that was against true
Christianity. Okay. So paganism is
fighting is clashing with Jesus or the
Christians at this time. Remember he
died. Now the gospel is about to be
permeated into the world. Now
question is, but if Christ was
destroyed, did he he and Christianity
lose? What do you think?
>> No, he didn't.
>> No, he didn't. But you notice though
that when um when Per Persia was on the
scene, the next king cannon that came
up,
they took the baton.
They were the ones that were they were
the willing winning faction
as it is when it comes to Christ. Even
though it appears that he died, but the
question is did Christianity lose? It
did not.
>> If anything, it became victorious.
>> Amen.
>> Am I right with that?
>> It became victorious. So then that would
mean then that since this was under the
jurisdiction of Rome, pagan Rome, Jesus
said to his disciples, "Go ye therefore
and teach all nations, baptizing them in
the name of the father and the son and
the holy ghost, teaching them to observe
all things whatsoever I have commanded
you." And you know what had happened in
Acts chapter 8 as mentioned that has
just commented earlier. Acts 8 2 and 4,
it says, "And they went everywhere
preaching the word." So what happened to
the word of God? It permeated through
the Roman um empire.
>> So that is the ruling faction of time.
It is Rome. But I want I want to be more
specific. It is Christianity.
True Christianity. But very for a very
short moment. Are you with me?
>> Um are you with me?
>> Repeat that because you said it's Rome
that's true Christianity.
>> Okay. So Jesus died under the
jurisdiction of Rome, didn't he?
>> Right.
Okay. So, it Romans the ruling faction,
right?
>> Right.
>> Paul writes to the Romans, right?
>> And you read if you read from Matthew
all the way to um to the book of
Revelation, what is the rule? What
kingdom is is the ruling faction?
>> Rome.
>> Rome. Right. So, it's Rome. But I want
you to understand during that time
period, Christianity is spreading. Yes
or no?
>> That's right. Okay. Yes. Yep.
Christianity is the one that's a ch but
I'm talking about true Christianity
right at this juncture but it's for a
very short period because I want you to
notice
okay
>> that's when the discip you know
everybody's getting killed for their
faith
>> yes exactly okay but but the more that
dies the more it spreads
>> that's right yep
>> okay so now we hit anchor point number
three then from 116b
all the way to 11:22
It was pagan Rome
if you will.
Now look what's going to happen. Okay, I
want you to notice. Let's jump about a
thousand years almost
from the time of Christ and I want you
to see what happens to Christianity. Now
Mikey, this is a very key text that we
must raise in on.
>> We're talking about Christianity. I want
you to notice. And after the league made
with him, he that is the king of the
north. Remember Rome, king of the north,
>> pagan Rome, king of the north, but tr
Christianity if you will, still still
pagan Rome under the under the umbrella
of pagan Rome shall work deceitfully.
Now we're if the la the nearest
interseed was Christ, the prince of the
covenant, we're talking about the
Christians. But I want you to notice um
according to the claw uh clause u Mikey
it says the league made with him. If
we're talking about Christianity it says
that Christianity will become deceitful
>> for he shall come up and shall become
strong with small people small people.
>> So he starts small. He the king of the
north shall enter peaceably even upon
the fattest places of the province. And
he the king of the north shall do that
which his fathers have not done nor his
father's fathers in other words his
ancestors.
>> So whatever Christianity is this today
what this verse is mentioning they are
doing opposite to what it was back then.
Are you getting this?
>> Oh yeah definitely. He shall scatter
among the prey and the spoiled and
riches and he the king of the north and
sh and he shall core forecast his
devices against the strongholds even for
a time
>> question.
Listen to this question.
Did a certain form of Christianity work
deceitfully and do that which his
fathers have not done nor his father's
fathers?
>> Definitely.
>> What was it?
>> Well, that was the beginning of
>> Christianity. Yeah, that was the
beginning of Catholicism.
>> Exactly.
>> Roman Christianity that was full of
pagan practices.
>> That's what the verse is telling us. And
mind you, I've never given you that
study before. I've never given you that.
>> This is my first time hearing all this
stuff, man.
>> Okay. I've never for and for the record,
I've never talked um to brother Mikey
about this.
>> I'm presenting this this subject to him
for the very first time. Would you vouch
for that?
>> Yes, definitely.
>> Okay. It's coming together people.
>> But now remember because paganism ties
its hand with Christianity, it is
corrupted.
>> Did you get it?
>> Yeah.
>> It works deceitfully.
It does that what his fathers or his
forefathers have not done.
>> Did not do.
>> So what the apostles did, what the
leaders of of of of the Christian
dispensation started off, now it goes to
a decline. Does that make sense so far?
>> Yeah.
This is what the text is telling us.
Okay. So, we now are focused on papleled
Christianity. So, we had Meo Persia,
then we had Greece, then we had pagan
Rome. Now, we're into the phase of paple
Rome.
Now, is paple Rome still in existence
today?
>> Papal Rome. Yeah.
>> Pap Rome. Yes, it is. Right. Okay. So,
now I want you to notice though. Now
Mikey, this is gonna this is really
gonna ache some people that think of it
of being something different. Okay,
>> check this out.
>> So we're looking at a map. Rome comes
from the north again. We got to look at
the map. We have pagan Rome. Now it's
hand is it hands the scepter over to
paple Rome. So I want you to look at the
screen. If we're looking at the time
period of papal Rome
>> again let me repeat this time repeat
this again we're we're we're talking the
time during the time of the inception
and within a thousand plus years when
Rome be and papal Rome began started
small then it became great I want you to
notice what the next text starts to tell
us during that time period that same
time period
right after Jesus dies and the spreading
of the of the gospel gets across the
world. But it then becomes corrupted by
that particular um um um um church, if
you will. The Bible says the king of the
north, which is peopleled Christianity,
shall stir up his power and his courage
against the king of the what?
>> South.
>> Mikey, if there's anything that anybody
needs to pay close attention to, it will
be this. cuz this is going to lock
>> for us the rest of the chapter, believe
it or not.
>> It says here, with a great army, and the
king of the south shall be stirred up to
battle with a very great and mighty
army. So, if we know that the papacy
during the dark ages was great, the
Bible's telling us that there's a
southern kingdom south of Jerusalem
that also is great. is a civil.
Obviously, you can tell that it's a
civil power because it says that it has
a great and mighty army. Yes or no?
>> Yes.
>> Did Rome did paple Rome have an army?
They did.
>> Oh yeah.
>> We'll get to in just a bit. But he shall
not stand for they shall forecast
devices against him. Question. What
specific country was last said to be the
king of the south? Do you remember that
when I said don't forget it?
>> The king of the south. Uh,
>> it was a specific location south of
Jerusalem that we gave
>> Greece. Yeah,
>> it was south. It was south of the
dividing line. Remember I said don't
forget that.
>> I remember I remember uh God's people
were in the middle Rome was up above.
>> No, no, no. It wasn't.
>> When you had you had the Seoos to the
north and the Tamies to the south.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. So, the Talm, what was
the what was the what was the place that
was named for the Talmies?
>> A specific location. It starts with an
E.
>> That was the first time I heard of this
stuff.
>> It starts with an E.
>> No. Remind me. Egypt. Oh,
>> Egypt.
>> Okay. I totally forgot.
>> Remember, remember that was specifically
noted.
>> Yeah,
>> that was the south. Okay. So, I want you
to notice my next qu these next verses.
I want you to notice this. The king of
the south shall be strong and the south
shall come to the king of the north and
shall also carry captives into Egypt.
This is what we read earlier.
>> And he shall continue more years than
the king of the north. Now listen to
what you see on the screen.
During the years into the rise of the
civil and religious Roman Catholic
Church, which is the king of the north,
did the king of the south, which is
Egypt, listen to this, transition itself
to becoming a different civil and
religious entity as well.
Think about the dark ages.
That's right.
>> Think about a power that during the
Roman Cathol the Roman Catholic times
that they were, you know, running their
train around um around the east
conference nations. Was there another
big faction that was south of Jerusalem
that was also a civil and religious
power?
>> So this is like a historical thing.
>> Exactly.
>> I'm I'm bad with history and geography.
>> Okay. Okay. So let's look at the other
clue. This is this is where this is why
we need to have the study. Okay. Yeah.
>> All right. So now it says here, "And he
meaning the king of the north shall stir
up his power and his courage against the
king of the south
>> with a great and great army. And the
king of the south shall be stirred up to
battle with a very great and mighty
army. But he, the king of the south
shall not stand. For they shall forecast
devices against him. Yay. They that feed
the portion of his meat shall destroy
him and his armies shall overthrow and
many shall fall down slain. Okay. And
then it goes on to say here, "And both
these kings, that is the king of the
north, king of the south
>> heart shall be to do mischief, and they
shall speak lies at one table, but it
shall not prosper, and it shall for for
yet the end shall be at the a time
appointed." Now,
>> I want this to be clear before we go on.
What this is saying is that if paple
Rome is the king of the north obviously
he's having battles with a king with a
great mighty army it has to be a I asked
a question was there a ci civil
religious power also in the king of
south but just just for the sake of the
context of understanding what is south
and north what this is telling us that
every what this verse is simply telling
us that whenever these battles were were
were were running its course when they
try to draw a truce
that was, you know, sit to try to to
make amends, if you will, and to try to
draw up um um terms to stop the
fighting. But you notice it says, "But
they shall speak lies at one table, and
it should not prosper." And
>> yeah,
>> when they would try to make a truce,
they would reig on their covenants, and
they will continue to continue to fight.
>> That's referring to the crusades.
>> Wow.
Okay.
Now Mikey, think about this again.
If we're talking about the Crusades,
who was the Crusaders
um um number one enemy?
Think of the South. Think about the
South.
>> Egypt.
>> I'm I'm not good with this.
>> Okay. Okay. Check this out. I'm going to
show you something. It's going to get
clear. Okay.
If you look up there,
>> I always heard about the Spanish
Inquisition or something.
>> No, that's okay. Spanish. Remember, if
you look at the Spanish, the Spaniards
is all the way to the left. That's more
on the north. Okay. Okay.
>> Now, remember that's there. Okay. So,
now Jerusalem is there. You got the king
in the north. Daniel's looking at a map.
So, what is the king in the south? If I
said the Crusades,
>> oh, Jerusalem. I'm
>> talking about Islam.
>> Islam.
>> A spiritual and political power. Wow.
>> Believe in Muhammad.
>> This is what the verse is telling us.
During the Crusades, during the
Crusades, you had this issue taking
place. Now, if you don't want to believe
me about what was north and what was
south,
>> brother, you got to remember who gets
stuck in the middle. It's God's people.
>> Yeah.
>> But check this out.
>> But I think of all the wars fought over
religion, the Crusades belong in their
own category. Now Mikey, make sure that
your listeners can hear that.
>> Yeah. Can everybody hear that clip?
Because we have issues with sound when
we do this way sometimes.
>> Let's see. I'm waiting on a response.
I heard it, but that doesn't always mean
anything.
>> But I think of all the wars fought over
religion, the Crusades belong in their
own category.
Did Did they get to hear that?
>> They're not responding. Okay,
everybody's saying yes. Perfect.
>> Okay, praise God.
>> Now, I want Okay, Mikey, I want you to
hear what History Channel tells us. I
want you to watch this. Okay, pay close
attention.
>> Okay,
>> but I think of all the wars fought over
religion, the Crusades belong in their
own category.
Listen, listen to this, Michael.
>> By the end of the 11th century, 600
years after the fall of Rome, the two
religions are great rivals.
Christianity dominates in the west and
north.
Islam in the east and south.
>> Did you hear that?
>> Yeah.
Islam in the south
>> and to the west and then Islam to the
north and to the east. You know the east
the children of the east if you will.
>> Yeah.
>> This is what this is what his and you
notice the dual map and for you to
understand that
I want you to understand what you're
about to hear. Now check this out. Now
let me go back to that to that portion
so people can really have it sink in.
Okay let's let's let's let let it sink
in.
By the end of the 11th century, 600
years after the fall of Rome, the two
religions are great rivals.
Christianity dominates in the west and
north.
Islam in the east and south.
Determined to curb the advance of Islam,
the Pope calls on Christians to take up
arms.
Their target, the holy city of
Jerusalem.
>> Wow.
On the eve of the Crusades, Jerusalem
under Muslim rule was actually a hotbed
of creativity and interreligious
dialogue. There were Jews, there were
Christians, there were Muslims. For the
most part, they lived in relative
harmony.
>> But each lays claim to the city. Jews
rever it as their ancient capital.
Muslims know it as Alkutz, the holy.
>> Now you notice
>> from here the prophet. Now, you notice
that
it said here that basically the
Christians drew arms. You saw that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Didn't the text say that they were
going to come with a mighty army?
>> Yeah.
>> And you notice there's a conflict
between the two? But it gets better.
Check this out.
>> Muhammad journeyed to heaven.
>> And for Christians,
Christ was crucified here.
It's amazing when you go to Jerusalem,
if you just stop for a second,
you'll see that these people actually
have more in common than they have that
are differences.
They are the sons and daughters of
Abraham.
Now, pay close attention, Mikey, okay?
To what they're going to say, what
they're going to say right now. Okay?
Check this out.
To all who join the crusade, Pope Urban
offers eternal salvation,
declaring,
>> "The Lord beseeches you to destroy that
vile race from the lands of our friends.
All who die by the way shall have
immediate remission of sins."
and like could sin as much as he liked.
And simply by going to the Holy Land, he
had been given forgiveness by the Pope.
He had been given his passport to
heaven. He could win fame. He could win
glory. And he could come back with
booty.
It is one of the most shameful
undertakings ever embarked upon by our
species.
>> So you hear what he said. You saw that
clip. Not my words, history's words.
They're telling us there was a faction
to the north and there was a faction to
the south.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> Mikey the Bible line. It was it was
Jerusalem.
>> So true.
>> This is the time that Daniel chapter 11
is referring to. And I want you to
notice something though. You notice that
their their um their quest was to
conquer Jerusalem. You notice that?
>> Yeah.
>> Let me ask you something. Do you think
that's happening today?
>> Uh, it's happening right now.
>> Exactly. Right. Let me tell you
something. There's unfinished business.
We'll get to that in just a bit. So,
we're talking about this this time
period. So, by 1099, the crusaders
finally conquered Jerusalem, but we know
that eventually was taken from them
because we have the Dome of the Rock
there. We'll get to that in just a bit.
In Daniel 11:29, this is very key. Um on
brother um Mikey it says here and at the
time appointed he shall return. He's
talking about the king of the north and
come toward the south the south was
Islam for it but it shall not be as the
former or as the latter or the next are
following. Let me break it down to you.
Okay. According to this text there are
three phases dealing with the king of
the north and the king of the south. How
many phases? Um um brother Mikey
>> three.
It says I have pointed there three
phase. Well, let's break it down. The
first phase is found the first and the
second phase is found in the latter part
of that verse. The first phase is
talking about the former which we just
read about talking about the civil issue
that Rome had to deal with. In other
words, the outside problems or the civil
issue that they were dealing with with
the Muslims. But and then the Bible says
or as the latter which is the second
phase that we're about to talk about
right now
>> and then the third and final phase the
Bible says and at the point of time he
shall return and come toward his house.
So what is telling us is in the future
he's going to come back but it's not
like how it was and what we just talked
about and it's not going to be just like
what we're going to talk about. There's
going to be there's unfinished business
that Daniel 11 is telling us. And this
is a bigger picture if we allow our
minds to wrap ourselves around this
concept. God is telling us that this
issue with the Muslims, it ain't just it
didn't it didn't just begin now. This
has been going on since the Crusades.
>> And let me I'm going to prove everything
to you today.
>> I'm going to show this to you. Okay. So
now the external phase that the that the
um that the crusaders had to deal with
was dealing with Islam. Remember they
took up arms and this was a battle after
battle after battle for years. Okay,
this was the external phase if you will.
Okay, the external phase. Oh, let me get
I don't know why this is bothering. So
you had the crusaders trying to always
go against the the Arabs or if you will
the Muslims. They wanted to stamp them
out. You s you heard what History
Channel just mentioned, okay, to step
out that vile race. So what was the next
or following issue that the PBC had to
face Mikey? During that same time period
where they had to deal with the civil
arena,
now they're going to have to deal with
the spiritual arena.
>> And what is it? Well,
the internal phase was dealing with the
reformation. You've heard of the
reformation, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Reformation. Okay. All right. So, now
the dark ages,
did they have an internal problem? The
Catholic Church, they did. It was the
reformers were, wasn't it?
>> Right. Martin Luther,
>> they did, right? How do we know?
>> Daniel 11:32-35
actually tells us this.
>> Actually tells us this. It goes on to
say, "And such as do wickedly against
the covenant shall he corrupt by
flatteries,
>> but the people that do know their God
shall do I mean, I'm sorry, let me
disconnect something here because I
think this is giving me problems here."
Okay. And such as do wickedly against
the covenant shall he corrupt by
flatteries, but the people that do know
their God shall shall be strong and do
exploits. This is talking about the
people of God during the dark ages.
Remember that Martin Luther nailed his
95 thesis church doors of Whittenberg.
>> This is during that time period. It goes
on to say, "And they that understand
among the people shall instruct many."
Did they do that? Yes, they did. Okay.
But as a result, what happened to them?
As you can see in the screen, Mikey,
what happened to the
>> They got martyed. Right. And yet shall
fall by the sword and by flame by
captivity and by spoil many days. Are
you catching this?
>> Yes. Wow.
>> Okay. This is the internal issue that
was taking place. Mikey,
>> what we just read earlier was the
external issue, the problem that they
had to deal with the civil arena, but at
the same time, they had an internal
problem. We'll get to that in just a
bit. Okay. The Bible goes on to tell us
that they the the reformers were it was
an uproar. It was basically insurrection
according to to to the Jews. I mean, I'm
sorry, according to to the papist. Okay.
Mhm.
>> The Bible goes on to say, "Now when they
shall fall, they shall be hoping with a
little help, but many shall cleave to
with them with flat to them with
flatteries." You know, they try to bribe
them.
>> They try to do everything that they can
do to coersse them and to try to win
them or wound them to the back to the
other side. The Bible goes on to say,
"And some of them of understanding shall
fall to try them to purge and to purge
and to make them white even to the time
of the end because it is yet for
appointed time." I want you to notice
here you have the time and the end and
be as at appointed time. Two times you
see that already. You've heard that in
verse 29 and you see it repeated again.
Let's go on. Did all of this happen
during the time of paper Christianity.
It sure did.
Now Ja Wy, I love this brother. When you
I don't know if you ever read this
quote, but listen, this is very very
interesting. JA WY in his book the
history of Protestantism volume one
chapter 18 had to say he mentioned he
gave an account of something that was
happening with the reformists during a
time that the Arabs or or the Muslims
were actually getting were were getting
to wipe them out man the west it was
getting ready to wipe them out but check
this out and I'm quoting again darkness
wy writes again darkness gathered around
and danger threatened the Protestant
church. Two terrible storms hung lower
in the sky in the skies of the world.
The one darkened the east and the other
was seen in the west. I want you to
think of remember when that video clip
one came from the south and from the
east,
>> right?
>> It's talking about entity. Okay, so this
is what this is the same entity that
they're referring to. The other was seen
rising in the west. It was in the west
is where Rome was actually seated at. So
there was two two fronts taking place.
It was the eastern tempest that will be
first to burst. We're talking about the
Muslims here. Then men thought and the
inhabitants of Germany turned their eyes
in that direction. In other words, they
see something bad is coming. They see
these men coming in their horses.
They're about to stamp us out. And watch
with alarm the trem and trembling the
progress of cl of the cloud that was
coming towards them. He goes on to say,
"Now Mikey, I I please don't miss this,
brother. Listen to what he says.
>> It is you, said the adherence of the old
creed, addressing the Lutherans." Now,
the Lutherans were the Protestants,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Who have brought this scourge upon us.
What scourge?
>> The Arabs that were coming in
>> that were getting ready to set at that
time during the Crusades. Okay. It is
you who have unlooed these angels of
evil. They come to chastise you for your
heresy. You have cast off the yoke of
the pope and now you must bear the yoke
of the Turk. Did you get it?
>> Yeah.
>> You have is the papacy or the Catholics
are blaming the Lutheran for what was
happening to them from the Turks or the
Arabs or the Muslims if you will. Are
you following me?
>> Mhm.
>> They now the the Lutheran respond not so
said Luther. It is God who had has un
loosed this army whose king is Abdon the
destroyer.
>> Abdon. Abdon is mentioned in revelation
chap. You can read it. You read about
the fourth fifth and the sixth trumpet.
We know what entity that was talking
about the Muslims.
>> Okay. They have been sent to punish us
for our sins, our ingratitude for the
gospel, our blasphemies, and above all,
our shedding of the blood of the
righteous.
>> Wow.
>> Mikey, what I'm simply just trying to
tell people is that there was an
internal problem that the Catholics had
and there was an external problem that
they had. What was the external? We just
talked about it. It was the Muslims.
>> Yeah.
>> But what was internal? Their own people.
These were the defectors of the faith.
These were the Protestants. They had to
fight. They had to fight a war on two
separate fronts. Are you getting this?
>> Yeah.
>> Two separate fronts. That's what
Revelation I mean, I'm sorry, Daniel
chapter 11 is telling us. There were
battles. Remember kings, there was
dominance. This is what it's all about.
The dominance that they wanted in the
civil arena is to conquer all of that
territory. Why? Because all of that
territory is mentioned in the Bible. And
the crown Jew was what? Jerusalem.
But who had jurisdiction over Jerusalem?
It was the Muslims. You just heard it.
Yeah.
>> Okay. And then now the B what history
tells us that the papist they turn on
their own people here the Lutheran were
ex- Catholics obviously and they're
blaming them for what was happening that
was the issue that was coming in from
the east and that was the Turks. It was
the Muslims. And now the Lutheran said
nuhuh. It's not because of us. It's
because of you.
>> Yeah.
>> That's what we're reading here. Okay.
Now Mikey, I want you to read this text
for me, brother.
>> And the king shall do according to his
will, and he shall exalt himself and
magnify himself above every god, and
shall speak marvelous things against the
God of gods.
Now, I want you to notice the
terminology, the words that are being
used. There's a king that's going to
speak marvelous things against the God
of gods. Wow, that's interesting.
Doesn't that sound like Daniel chapter
7? That little horn.
>> Yep.
>> In Daniel chapter 7:8, it says, "Behold,
in this horn a mouth speaking great
things." And in verse 20, that horn that
had eyes and a mouth that spake very
great things,
>> finding a match. So in Daniel 11:36, it
goes on to say, "And the king shall do
according to his will and shall exalt
himself and magnify himself above every
god, and shall speak marvelous things
against the god of gods." Now, did the
Apostle Paul foresee a man that would
exalt himself above God in the future?
He sure did.
>> You look at the New Testament, read 2
Thessalonians chapter 2:3 and 4. The
Bible says, "Let no man therefore, let
no man deceive you by any means,
>> for that day not come except there come
a fallen away first, and that the man of
sin be revealed, the son of predition."
The word predition simply means
destruction or utter destruction. Okay?
But I want you to notice it uses the
clause man of sin and the son of
predition meaning the same entity. All
right? And what the Bible is simply
telling us too is that the fallen away
or rather the second coming of Jesus is
not going to take place until there's a
decline in Christianity. That's what
simply is trying to say.
>> Okay?
>> And that something needs to be revealed
first before the second coming of
Christ. And that is the man of sin or
the son of predition. And then he goes
on to say, who opposeth and exaltth
himself above all that is called God or
that is worshiped, so that he as God
siteth in the temple of God, showing
himself that he is what? God.
>> God. Wow.
>> What's the underlying words that you see
there, Mikey?
>> The exalteth himself.
>> Didn't we read that back in Daniel
chapter 11?
>> We read. So, we're speaking of the same.
So, that would then suggest that Paul
understood Daniel.
>> Wow.
He studied Daniel as well. Now, is it
true then that the papacy claims to be
God on earth? What do you think?
>> Def. Absolutely. Yeah, they do.
>> Okay. So, let's read it. Pope Pas the
11th quoting his own words. Check this
out. You know that I am the holy father,
the representative of God on the earth,
the vicor of Christ, which means I am
God on the earth. Now, let me be clear.
This is not attack against Catholics.
This is not what this is about. This is
not We're not talking about individuals.
This is not what this is about. We're
talking about the system. I come from
that church. U many of my family members
are still in that church. We love them.
We I love Catholics as people. God died
for them just like he died for you and
I. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> So, we're not talking about the people.
And I know sometimes when we hear
something negatively spoken about our
church or an organization we belong to,
sometimes we can take offense to it. But
this is not the purpose of that. If you
want to know, just read your history.
You will understand what the church had
done. Now again I didn't give you
context to the previous um chapters
Daniel chapter 2 Daniel chapter 7 for
the sake of time today but we will talk
about if you want to in the future so
you can understand what took place with
the decline of Roman Catholic Church and
everybody knows that there was a decline
I mean if you read your history that is
now
>> in Daniel chap now I want you to notice
what verses do you see up there um Mikey
>> Daniel 11:36 and 37
>> okay so you notice we're getting close
to the ending of Daniel chapter um
chapter 11, it only goes to 45.
Okay? And it goes on to say, "Neither
shall he regard the God of his fathers,
nor the desire of women?"
>> I want you to catch that.
Do do Catholic priests are at least when
they take that role, are they supposed
to be married?
>> They take a vow of celibacy.
>> Okay, very good. As a matter of fact,
you can read this in their catechism.
Check this out. Catechism of the
Catholic Church page 440. Not my words,
their words. All the ordained ministers
of the Latin church with the exception
of permanent deacons are normally chosen
from among men of faith who live like
live a celibate life and who remain
celibate for the sake of the kingdom of
heaven. Celibacy is a sign of this new
life to the service of which the
church's minister is con consecrated.
Accepted with a joyous heart. Celibacy
radiantly proclaims the reign of God.
They're telling you. So if not my words,
their words. So when the when the when
when when the gospel literally states
the following that they're not going to
desire women. Wow.
>> They're telling you right there. So
we're talk remember we're staying
intact. The king of the north is still
that same king of the north. Did you get
that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. We're still talking about the same
entity. So if we still have Roman
Catholicism to the north, do we still
have Islam to the south? We sure do. I
didn't I never read or I never I can I
can't see at least on the news that
they've evaporated from the face of the
planet.
>> I want you to think about that. Okay.
>> All right. Now, this is the second
phase.
>> In the 16th century, the pope is more
like a king.
>> The pope is more like a what?
>> King.
>> Not my words. That's um History
Channels,
>> right?
>> Let's hear it again.
In the 16th century, the Pope is more
like a king ruling over a large
territory known as the Papal States.
>> He's the largest single land owner in
Italy. And that's going to mess up the
papacy's spiritual authority by
entangling it in worldly authority.
>> Popes collect taxes, use armies to
confiscate their enemy's riches, and
amass fortunes by asserting their power
like kings.
But the wealth they accumulate allows
them to create the most cherished
monuments of the Vatican.
St. Peter's Basilica, the Systeine
Chapel Ceiling, the Raphael Stanza, even
the apostolic palace, all are created in
the 16th century by these wealthy popes.
>> Now, you notice what they said that
again they're using the word king.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Some people would say no. People
say, "No, there were never. It was never
a king." Well, then why is history? And
by the way, this clip is not against the
Roman Catholic Church. This is actually
a pro documentary for the for the Roman
Catholic Church.
>> Okay? So, this is not trying to throw
stones upon the church. I'm just sharing
this video with you to let you know,
look at what they're saying. They're
usually they're using the terminology as
king. Not my words, their word.
>> Okay, let's continue.
>> Of the church's power and its
corruption.
The papacy becomes the play thing of
these huge families from throughout
Italy. Those families begin to rise to
power and those families after they rise
to power have so much money that they
can indulge in trying to take over power
at a larger level. The papacy becomes
the biggest jewel in the crown. What
better thing could a mother or father
want for their boy than that their boy
would be pope? One such family is the
Boures. In 1492, Cardinal Rodrigo Boura
becomes Pope Alexander V 6th when mule
loads of family silver are used to bribe
the cardinals into electing him. Once
Pope, he poisons his rival cardinals and
then accepts payoffs to fill their
seats.
>> Now, you notice what they're saying?
Again, this is History Channel giving
you the history of the Roman Catholic um
um church. Does it sound like it was
corrupted?
>> Yeah,
>> they were worked right. This is what the
this is what history is confirming. And
look at one of his own members say.
Check this out.
>> It's certain that there were popes who
were not the holiest of men. You had a
certain corruption which set in with
individuals who became ambitious for
secular power and unfortunately they
were not great times in the history of
the church. The folks lived like kings.
They were corrupt. They were debauched.
They had lavish parties. They built
sumptuous palaces for themselves. They
made Paris Hilton look like a popper.
These are the popes. These terrible
popes. these awful popes who created the
very things that flocks of pilgrims go
to the Vatican to see today. There's an
irony.
>> So, you notice these popes, these
terrible popes, and this guy is a
Catholic himself. He's just a historian.
But they're telling out of their own
mouth, Mikey. You catch that out of
their own mouth, brother.
>> Yeah.
>> But look at this last phase. Check this
out of this clip.
In the Middle Ages, the pope was a
general because the most efficient way
to spread the gospel was with armies.
And sometimes there were forced
conversions, sometimes there were
crusades, sometimes there were terrible
sins committed uh in the name of the
gospel by the by Catholic leaders, the
people who are supposed to embody those
gospel values.
>> Through the ages, the church's message
has remained the same. But the Vatican
has found a less bloody way to spread
the gospel.
>> Well, Mike, whenever I share this this
particular video, I mean, I let the
video speak for itself.
>> Yeah.
>> Because sometimes if I say it, I don't
know what I'm talking about. So, I guess
if I don't know what I'm talking about,
these people definitely don't know what
they're talking.
>> Yeah. Um, I see some disagreement in the
chat, but I'm not sure why because,
brother, you made this so clear. like I
I came in this blank slate because I
I've looked at it and I can't I couldn't
figure it out. But when you showed it
from the map and the scriptures line
upon line, that's all you've shown.
Scripture, history, uh geography,
it all makes sense. It all lines up.
>> No, it it's fine. It's fine. I knew I
was going to I would get flack for it. I
I know it. I mean, it's it's okay,
though. I mean, people are free to to to
submit their judgment upon what they
believe, and it's fine. You know what?
But this is what I say. Um, you know,
again, I'm I'm I'm giving you my
evidence to it and I'm giving you
everything and and we're not done. We we
if anything, we're just getting started.
>> Okay.
>> Unfortunately, I know people from from
the church that I belong to will really
be ma the main ones. Some I'm not saying
all some will be the main ones that
would try to attack this um this this
this point that I'm going or this
trajectory and or rather th this I'm
trying to get gather the right words um
my belief and the identity of who's the
king of the north king of the south.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah. But I you know I me being somebody
who's looking at this with a blank slate
I can't understand the issue. I don't
why I I don't understand why I would be
offended or think this is wrong or
blasphemous in any kind of way. What is
the other alternative
that people say?
>> I know. I know. And and again, people
have brought up to being what it is. And
it's so interesting that
if if I'm wrong, I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm
fine. But you're going to have to
present to me the evidence that you will
require me to present as well to say
that I'm wrong. You can't say that I'm
wrong, but yet don't present the
evidence. And many of us are are are
just sold on one form of the gospel, if
you will, or one um how should I say
interpretation of Daniel chapter 11, and
we close our minds to anything else.
>> What is another interpretation?
>> Oh, we'll get to that in just a bit.
Okay.
>> I can't I can't just sell it right now.
Okay. All right. Just finish this phase.
Okay. So, we're dealing with the second
phase. Okay. But so far, Mikey, at least
for you and your platform, you're the
one that invited me. Do you are you
understand at least the majority of the
point that I'm bringing to the table?
>> Yeah. And every the majority of people
in the chat are seeing it for the first
time or already believe it. And yeah,
man. This is this is legit.
>> Yeah. And we're going to have people
that disagree. And that's again, that's
perfectly fine. God bless their heart.
We love them. Okay. We love them. We're
not here to jab at them. I know people
are going to jab at me. They jab out
other ministers of the gospel that even
preach the same thing. And that's fine.
We just still got to go straight
straight ahead. Now, again, I and before
we go on, if there's anybody that
disagrees with me, hey, I'm fine to
discuss it. But please, before you do,
make sure you have the evidence as well,
okay? Because again, this is not this
not meant to be exhausted, even though
it seems to be exalted right now, but
again, we're giving a lot of commentary
to it as we go on. But anyways, let's
just move forward. Okay? So, we're
getting ready to close out on the second
phase that Daniel 11 is referring to
because there's three phases. We already
identified there's three phases. Okay.
Now, Daniel chap 11 verse um 2a was
dealing with Persia. Point number two of
the anchor point was Daniel 11b and 2B,
I'm sorry. Um all the way to 11:16a was
dealing with the empire of Greece. Then
from 11:16b
all the way to 11:22 was dealing with
pagan Rome. And then we knew that
eventually pagan Rome handed the scepter
over to paple Rome. And this is where
we're getting to verse 39 because
remember I told you from the outset or
at the outset that verses 40 to 45 is
really the one that's the that's the
hottest of the potatoes if you will.
Okay. This is the one that is at least
coming from the church or that I I
belong to a lot of people tend to argue.
I I I try not to argue with a lot of
people because of course that's what all
they want to do. Just argue argue
>> until they, you know, slam dunk on your
head. This is what it's supposed to be
and it can't be anything else. That's
fine.
>> I'm willing to dialogue with people.
That's fine. But again, if the evidence
doesn't stand on its own, that's fine.
Show me something else and I I'll be
good with that. All right. So now Mikey,
if there's anything that from this point
on that you have to pay close attention
to, it would be this because this is
where remember how you mentioned about
um um Daniel chapter 9 that they're
saying that people say about that it's
talking about the seven-year
tribulation.
>> The reason why they can say that is
because people don't study Daniel the
whole Daniel chapter 9. They don't study
everything. Go to those last two verses
and they can make up anything out of it.
But when you break the prophecies down
step by step, it starts to make sense to
people say, "Hold up, this cannot be
applied to the future. It has to be
applied to the past." Speaking of Daniel
chapter 9, the Messiah, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Same concept over here.
>> A lot of us start want to deal with the
latter part of Daniel chapter 11 and we
don't really care the of the former
part. You can't do that. In order to
understand the latter part, you got to
understand the former and you got to
break it down to understand who are the
players in verses 40 to 45. Now, as you
see posted on your screen, the question
there reads as follows. So, what is the
third and final phase of papleled
Christianity, which is still the king of
the north? Now,
it's clear and I want you to notice in
Daniel 11:40 says the following, Mikey.
And at the time of the end
shall the king of the south push at him
and the king of the north shall come
against him like a whirlwind with
chariots and with horsemen and with many
ships. Now are we Mike and I'm asking
you this question. Are we living in the
time of the end or the end of time now?
>> Absolutely.
>> Okay. So my next question will be the
following. Is papleled Christianity
still live and well today?
>> Oh yeah. Absolutely.
>> Very good. Okay. So if in the time of
the yen paperled Christianity is still
the king of the north who then at that
same time the king of the south
>> Islam.
>> It has to be. It has to be.
>> Let's look just to be clear because this
is where I know people some there
probably people fuming right now that
are watching. Some people that are that
are disagreeing with this. They're
fuming out their heads right now. Okay.
But let's look at one more clue to
determine who this king of the south
could be. Okay. I want you to notice the
words that are highlighted in these
particular texts. The Bible goes on to
say, "And he, the king of the north,
shall enter also into the glorious
land." We're going to tackle that that
that that clause there in just a bit.
And many countries shall be overthrown.
I want you to notice the language that
is being used there. But these shall not
escape out of his hand, even Edom and
Moab and the chief and the chief of the
children of Ammon.
And he shall, the king of the north,
shall stretch forth his hand also upon
the countries, and the land of Egypt
shall not escape, but he shall have
power over the treasures of gold and of
silver. We're talking about the king of
the north. He's going to have power over
the treasures of gold. Doesn't that
>> sound like chapter 18,
>> Revelation chapter 13?
>> It does to me. And over all the precious
things of Egypt and Libyans and the
Ethiopians shall be ahead of steps. You
know, it's very interesting. A lot of my
dear friends that um oppose this view
would like to spiritualize this away.
>> They would say probably it was literal
back then, but now it's spiritual.
That's easy to debunk.
>> But for the sake of the context to stay
on point for those that are actually
wanting to hear and to identify the
players in these last days, I want you
to notice the highlighted words. You see
the highlighted words?
>> Mhm.
>> What?
>> We got Edom. Well, we got he, king of
the north. We got Edom, Moab, Aman,
Egypt, Libyans, and Ethiopians.
>> Okay. Now, I want you to notice, what do
all these have in common today?
>> You're getting me with the other.
>> Wow.
>> Now, people might want to argue about
Edom, Moab, and Ammon. Don't worry,
we'll take care of that in just a bit.
>> Okay, we'll take care of that just a
bit. But that's what we have in common.
Remember,
>> Daniel's looking at a map.
>> Okay,
>> he's looking at a map. Always keep this
in mind.
>> See the ancient boundaries where you see
Libya, Egypt, and Ethiopia. That's the
ancient. But today, this is how you see
it. Egypt, Libya, and Ethiopia. I want
you to think about those. The religion
that's more predominantly growing in
these nations. Just think about that.
Okay. Now, so does the Bible say that
there will be a third and final conflict
between these two opposing earthly
forces? Well,
>> I believe it does. In Daniel 11:40, it
tells us, "And at the time of the end,
which I believe we're living at, shall
the king of the south push,"
that means to wage war against him. And
the king of the north, which is paperled
Christianity, shall come with the
whirlwind, with chariots, and with
horsemen, and with many. That sounds
like a military mic with to me does.
>> Absolutely.
>> Now you know what the first part of of
the verse is telling us. The king of the
south if I am suggesting and I do
believe it is Islam is going to do
something to strike at the papacy if you
will. I don't think believe I don't
believe it happen has happened yet.
>> But we know that the tensions are rising
at least against the west. That's us.
Yes or no?
>> Yes. And the Bible says when Islam
or those that are of that faith
try to do something that's going to be
very I mean it's going to be very severe
that we the west in connection to
Catholicism are is going to react to it
and we are going to mount up the horses
if you will and we are going to push and
attack
or rather rather rather let me just
rephrase it. We're going to wage war
that history has never seen before.
>> This is what the verse is telling us.
We'll get into that. What could this
push by the king of the south against
peopleled Christianity possibly mean?
Could it be terrorism,
>> radical Islam?
Well, check this out. Are radical
Muslims wanting to conquer and destroy
Rome, king of the north, today? What do
you think?
I'll be honest, I'm not sure.
>> Okay. Well, seeing what the headline
does. Check this out. This comes from
CBN. I want you to hear. I'm going to
give some commentary to it, but listen
to what they have to say.
>> The Islamic State has a plan to conquer
Rome.
>> Did you hear that?
>> Yes. It sounds crazy, but ISIS believes
the conquest of Rome is central to its
mission.
>> Now, this was years ago.
>> This didn't happen now. What you what
you're watching here came out years ago.
>> Okay.
>> Right. So, check this out. Let me replay
it. Okay.
>> The Islamic State has a plan to conquer
Rome. Yes, it sounds crazy, but ISIS
believes the conquest of Rome is central
to its mission and necessary to fulfill
what Islam teaches was the prophecy of
Muhammad and to prepare the return of
the Muslim Messiah, the Madi. Robert
Spencer is the author of The Complete
Infidel's Guide to ISIS.
>> ISIS thinks that Rome is one of its
primary goals.
>> Did you hear that?
>> Yeah, dude. This is crazy.
>> Brother, this unfinished Oh, brother. We
We haven't even gotten to the real meat
of it yet.
>> But check this out. Check this out. But
this video came out several years ago.
Okay.
>> Okay.
>> Now, I want you to think in connection
to today and what's going on in our
world today. Okay. But just think of
just hear what he has to say. and that
it is in its timetable. It has a
timetable wherein in the next 10 years
by the year 2025 it hopes to bring about
>> final struggle between good and evil or
between the Muslims and the non-Muslims
and that uh one of the chief stepping
stones to that Armageddon battle is the
conquest of Rome which they think
they're going to have they're going to
be able to do within the next 5 years
that is by 2020. Muslim
>> wow
>> that this been already in planning now
you know when when people talk in the
future you know they project that things
are going to happen
>> but it's not what happens is when we say
wow but they did talk about it in the
past you follow what I'm saying it's
like whenever they talked about digital
ID and all that we've heard it in the
years past
>> but now see it happening today you
follow what I'm saying right
>> now they might been off a year or two or
a couple years
>> but are they off with um are they off
with um how should I say um what's the
word I just had at the tip of my tongue
with um enforcing those type of thing no
that listen we're right at we were so
right
>> for the system to to to actually the
word right I wanted to use was implement
>> to implement those very things that they
were already talking about 5 10 20 30
years ago
>> am I right with that
>> yes absolutely
>> we've already hit that time right same
thing when it comes to this supposed
prophecy now you heard what Robert
Spencer said he was about a year 2025.
This was this was over four or five
years ago that this clip came out. We
just turned over to 2026.
>> Yeah, 2025 is super prophetic. Anyway, I
mean esoteric writers like Alice Bailey
talking about the externalization of the
hierarchy and
>> it's already happened.
>> Yeah, it's already happened. I mean they
>> they gave
>> Yeah. 2025 they were telling us that uh
oh there's drones. We don't know what
they are. They're not good or they're
not bad. just keep shopping. And uh the
military's having US congressional
hearings. Yeah, we talked to non-human
intelligences. We don't know if they're
alien. They could be interdimensional
beings. I mean, like this is all
everything's happening exactly according
to Satan's prophec prophetic timeline.
>> And you know what, Mikey, I will I'm
going to make a I'm going to make a
statement here. I say Satan has a
program
that he I mean I I guess we can name the
program. How should I say it? Um how
what's the terminology I should give? I
should I say um um oh
there's a terminology that I wanted I
just for the life of me I I can't recall
it but basically he has something for
every soul.
>> Oh yeah. In other words, that it doesn't
matter if you love cartoons, it doesn't
matter if you love sports, it doesn't
matter if you love science, it doesn't
matter if you love news, you like
politics. He has something for each and
every category.
>> He's got a tackle box full of bait
>> flavor for
>> to sweep you under under his deception.
We think that he doesn't. Yes, he does.
>> Yep.
>> Even within the church, he has it.
>> We think that no, the church is so
sanctified. No, he has his listen, he
has his pawns within the church as well.
Absolutely.
>> Okay, now let's get back to this video
now. Let's hear what he what brother
wait until the latter end of this video.
Wait until the latter
>> ends say Muhammad prophesied that the
two great Roman cities would be
conquered. Constantinople and Rome.
Constantinople today is Istanbul, a
Muslim city. Rome remains to be
conquered.
>> Once Rome is conquered in this
>> within the next 5 years and then Israel
will follow shortly after. They also
believe that during this time period,
they're going to conquer Saudi Arabia
and Iran.
>> Now, before you laugh, consider that
phase one of the Islamic State's plan to
take Rome may already be underway,
flooding Europe with ISIS fighters under
the cover of the refugee crisis.
>> They're not talking about doing it by
conventional armies. They're talking
about doing it by overwhelming these
lands with sympathizers from within and
an influx of other people from outside.
The Islamic State reveals part of its
plan in its publication, Black Flags
from Rome. It will use sleeper cells and
expects to get help from Muslims serving
in European armies and from non-Muslim
sympathizers. It also wants to fire
missiles into Italy that it has captured
on the battlefield. This is a threat
that is hard to be concerned about for
Italian and foreign.
>> Now, you notice Mikey, they have their
aim on Rome. Why out of all places?
>> Why out of all? Because Rome is
considered the spiritual hub for the
world for the west.
>> Wow.
>> That's the reason why
they when you got to keep this in mind.
Many people don't realize this. When m
you know how we look at Muslims, we look
at okay, Muslims in general, they're all
Muslims. No, they're Shiite and Sunni
Muslims that they're fighting always
together. Yeah. Against each other. Yes
or no?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. Right. But when we look at them,
oh y'all just Muslims. Guess what? They
do the same with us. They see us as Cath
they see they see Protestants.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean you're Protestants. We No. No.
We're against the Catholic church. Oh,
no. The Catholic Church is against the
Protestant. But when they look at us,
they look at us as Catholics.
>> Yeah.
>> And they see the West when they look at
the West, they see the church's leader
as the Pope of Rome. You get You get
what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. I think most of most of just your
regular public person, you know, you go
up to any random person on the street
and say, "What do you think of when you
think of Christianity?" They're like,
"Oh, I don't know, the Pope." And you
know, Hollywood always shows
Christians like they go to church and
there's a Catholic priest. You know,
>> isn't that interesting? And that's been
going out for has been happening for
years in Hollywood movies, right?
>> Yeah.
>> All right, let me finish this. policy
expert Emmanuel Odol Langi.
>> The concern should be commensurate to
the reality of the threat. The Islamic
State does not pose that kind of a
threat today.
>> He says Europe faces more pressing
problems because of ISIS. I think that
the much larger threat that we are
concerned with in Europe is with the
lone wolf terrorist who plots uh a
terror outrage against a school, against
a supermarket, against a shopping mall,
against an airport. And it is hard to
see how ISIS could conquer a city of 3
million people in a nation of 60 million
people. But it is not hard to see ISIS
attempting it. The conquest of Rome has
been a primary goal since the beginning
of the Islamic State.
>> You hear that?
>> Yeah.
>> It's been a primary goal. Not my words.
They're saying it.
>> They think that the conquest of Rome
will be the complete sign of Islam's
superiority over Christianity and defeat
of Christianity.
>> They also see the fall of Rome on an
esqueological timeline that will
culminate in a battle near Dabek, Syria,
their version of Armageddon. And they
think that once this battle takes place
at Dabi, this final battle which they
see coming in by 10 years,
>> Mikey, I want you to notice it says Dabi
there, the failed crusade.
>> And what's there in the center Basilica?
>> Yeah.
>> And they planted their flag. That is the
objective, brother.
>> Wow.
>> And they know that the America is just
it's just it's just a military might.
>> But that's the church. Remember, it's a
civil religious power. And we know
according to Revelation chapter 13, we
know that America will be used as the
military means in order to conquer or to
inflict the you know or rather to
implement that um that mark of the beast
>> right
>> that if it's by force and America is
going to be the one that's going to be
used as the pawn to do so. Wouldn't you
agree with that?
>> Yeah, absolutely. Yeah.
>> Now in 2025 that the Muslims will battle
the non-Muslims in this town in northern
Syria and then Jesus the Muslim prophet
and the Madi will return to the earth
and they will together conquer and
Islamize the world
>> if their plan for Rome succeeds.
>> Now Mikey, just hear what they got to
say next. If you think you heard
everything, brother, you haven't heard
it. Look, look how this clip finishes
off. IS says it will throw homosexuals
from the top of the leaning tower of
Pisa. But the chief target is Vatican
City in Rome. And the main event as they
see it will be the beheading of the Pope
in St. Peter's Square broadcast and live
streamed to an international audience.
>> There was a Polish convert to Islam
recently who has joined the Islamic
State and he said, "Once we take Rome,
we're going to carry out mass beheadings
in St. Peter's Square." And so this is
the plan to to convert St. Peter Square
into a huge site of executions of people
considered to be the enemies of Allah,
chief among them the pope, in order to
uh cow and frighten the rest of the
world into submitting to their rule.
>> It's a plan that for now has little
chance of success. But in his new book,
The ISIS Apocalypse, author and expert
William
>> So I just want to just bring that point
so you see what they're saying, not my
words. That's what they're saying.
>> Yeah.
>> But Daniel chapter 11, Mike, he's
already told us that there's unfinished
business.
>> And you got to think about, I'll get to
this point. In order to be the ruling
faction of the world, the ruling power
of the world, that is the Vatican. They
have to also conquer these areas that
have high real resources. And what's the
real sources? Oil.
>> Yeah. In order to have the monetary
jurisdiction over the world, you got to
control that, don't you?
>> How you going to control it? If they're
not going to submit to you, this is the
different religion that says, "No, we're
not going to follow the eastern um relig
I mean the western religion, but by
force, will they do it?" That might
change some things. So, let's move
forward.
>> But why else will radical Muslims desire
to to destroy Rome? Now, we're going to
get some history here. Now this is more
the historical element. Okay. Now check
this out. Check this out.
>> Or one might mention the controversial
rally.
>> Now this was this was a clip that came
from um another documentary that came
out years ago. And in this port in this
u this segment of the clip is going to
start off. You see um um Bush um Jr.
here. This is after the aftermath of um
911. hear what he says and they're gonna
comment upon this the statement that
George Bush makes. Okay, check this out.
>> Or one might mention the controversial
rallying cry delivered in the aftershock
of 9/11.
>> This crusade,
this war on terrorism,
uh, it's going to take a while.
>> George Bush says, "Let's have a crusade
against terror."
How does that sound to you?
>> What it indicates for us is like a war.
Bad people and
>> bad people.
>> Bloodshed.
>> Everything I think of.
>> Yeah.
>> But in in Britain, we talk about we're
going to have a crusade to stamp out
drunkenness.
>> Do you?
>> Yeah. We're going to have a crusade
against drugs. We're going to have a
crusade to make sure that people,
>> you know, don't uh talk on their mobile
phone whilst driving.
>> That's surprising because it really has
a very negative connotation here. Did
you hear what he said? What she said?
>> That terminology said that doesn't fall
well with the Eastern world
>> because they know their history,
brother.
>> Right.
>> And they knew what was the purpose.
Remember we showed you the clip about
Pope Urban II. Their mission was to
stamp out what quote unquote that vow
race. That's what they said. It was a
direct quote.
Mikey, they have not forgotten.
>> No. This has been a battle since that
time period and it's still been going
on. Now listen to a little bit more of a
historical element to this as well.
>> Jerusalem is less than half a mile wide.
Within her walls, the crusaders had
massacred an estimated 30,000 Muslims
and Jews.
>> Who were the ones that that massacred
them? Now, this is this is not against
the behalf of the church, but look at
what they're saying. M
>> their focus on the Roman Catholic Church
and what the Roman Catholic Church did
during this dark period of of their
history.
>> News of the slaughter rocked the Islamic
world.
>> The Crusades
had a very deep impact on Arab society.
one they were seen as a barbarian
incursion and stories of those crusades
are still told in cafes uh and in
families as if they happened yesterday.
This is something quite striking.
>> And so whenever the west has invaded
that region again, uh people say it's
another crusade. Which is why after the
awful events of 9/11, when the American
president inadvertently, one assumes,
said we now have to wage a crusade
>> to stop this, a shiver went down the
collective spine of the Islamic world
because they felt they knew what was
coming.
>> You hear that? Yeah,
>> in their minds, um, Mikey, they feel
that there's unfinished business from
the West. And that's why there there
it's like almost now today with Iran,
there a rally cry rallying cry. They
feel that now the West under this
administration is targeting them to wipe
them out.
>> Wow.
>> And we think this is just what happened
in Iran is is is going to be over.
>> Let me tell you something. Seen the
beginnings of it.
>> Yeah.
In order for for um Rome, in order to
have full jurisdiction, you got to stamp
out your opposers. Now, remember, this
is the civil arena.
They're going to have to take care of
the internal arena. These were the
defectors, which are called Protestants.
They've been doing that already,
>> but it's going to get worse. There's
unfinished on both business on both
ends. Did you get Are you getting this,
Mike?
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> Okay. They they it's fun in this time
they're gonna have their ducks in a row
because they're gonna say we're not
gonna say make the same mistake that we
made back then.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Oh yeah. They're prepared.
>> Now what did Check this out because a
lot of people missed this. What did then
presidential candidate Donald Trump say
in 2016 about the radical about what
radical Islam or ISIS really wants to
attack Ro? Now many people missed this.
This is during his first running of you
know for the election.
Mikey this went over people's heads. I
caught it when it happened. I said it
shocked me that he said that. I said
this brother knows something. Check this
out. First, I just wrote this out very
quickly about the pope. Do you want to
hear it? Should I read it to you? Okay.
>> He actually said that maybe I'm not a
good Christian or something. It's
unbelievable. Which is really not a nice
thing to say. So, it's a response from
Donald Trump. It says if and when the
Vatican is attacked by ISIS, you know,
>> listen,
>> ISIS, their primary trophy, very few
people know this. I read this about two
months ago. Nobody even believed it.
Their primary thing, you've seen what
they've done all over the Middle East.
Their primary goal is to get to the
Vatican. That would be their ultimate
trophy. They want to do what they did to
all of these magnificent artifacts and
all of the beautiful museums that
they've totally destroyed all over the
Middle East. Right there. And I didn't
know this. I read this like four or five
months ago. I made mention of it two
months ago and everyone said, "What are
you talking about?" They thought like,
"I'm kidding. It's true." And now there
are stories about it. Not big stories,
but there are stories about it. And I
was checked by one of the reporters that
said they don't want to talk about the
and he called up and apologized. The big
thing they want to get to the Vatican.
So if and when the Vatican is attacked
by ISIS, which as everyone knows is
ISIS's ultimate trophy, I can promise
you that the Pope would have only wished
and prayed that Donald Trump would have
been president because
>> heard what he said.
>> Yeah. That's wild, man.
>> Mikey, that was back in 2015.
>> Yeah, this is like predictive
programming,
>> brother.
It's more than that, brother. More than
that.
>> Oh, yeah. It's prophecy
>> because Yeah. predictive programming is
simply saying it before it happens so
that everybody's programmed so that when
they see it, they're desensitized to it.
That's basically what it is.
>> It's like, but it's Satan's plan, but
God told us in his word. So, it's like
the Bible prophesied it thousands of
years ago. Satan's doing his thing by
putting it in our faces, predictive
programming. And really, he's playing
both sides. This is the Hegelian
dialectic. He's
>> and and and Mikey, I'm sorry to cut you
off, brother.
>> I'm This is my personal belief. People
can look at me and they can say whatever
they want to say. It doesn't really
matter.
>> I'm not here against this president
here.
>> People can like him, hate him, love him.
It doesn't matter. I believe he's
another person that should be prayed
for.
>> I believe that anybody that we discuss
about on this platform should always be
prayed for whether they're doing things
right or wrong.
>> We need to be praying for because they
were souls that Jesus died for as well.
>> I don't care what faith, what walk of
life you're a non-believer. I don't care
what it is that you do in life. These
people here are a lot of them are being
used as pawns for the devil.
>> Pawns
God can also save them.
Yeah,
>> I believe that
even though they pushed the wrong
buttons, I believe that if we pray for
our leaders, and the Bible tells us
that, Paul, the Apostle Paul tells us to
do that. If we pray for our leaders, we
don't know. Imagine this, Mikey.
Imagine, cuz people don't like this man
in in in office right now. Imagine the
prayers of people. You know what I
believe? I believe that's the
Nebuchadnezzar who you see on the
screen. I believe that's the
Nebuchadnezzar of our day.
>> Yeah,
>> that's what I believe. Now remember
Nebuchadnezzar was saved at the end.
>> Yeah.
>> And was Nebuchadnezzar haughty? Was he
arrogant? Oh, he sure was. Read it in
the Bible. Go exterior to the Bible and
find out. And to me, we found a we found
a good match. Now, I believe he Biden um
um we can name name the leaders of the
world. It doesn't matter. We need to be
praying for them. There are other people
that get on platforms um um Mikey and I
and I'll submit to you and I'll say this
and I say this on my personal platform
that they tend to talk negative I mean
really really negative about the
Catholic Church about Muslims about um
you know I just name it any entity that
they they totally oppose not me you know
why because I sincerely believe that
they are sinners just like you and I
that we that need a savior just like you
and I.
>> Absolutely.
>> Okay. And who is to say that by our
prayers we get when we make it to the
kingdom of heaven and we see these
people come and embrace us and they tell
us out of their own mouths thank you for
your prayers
>> is because of your prayers that I'm here
today. Are you following what I'm
saying?
>> Yeah. That would be amazing.
>> That's what I believe in the power of
prayer and the power of our God.
>> Yeah.
>> So I don't I'm just bringing the news
but it's no no I'm not throwing stones
against these characters. I'm just
saying look at what's happening in the
headlines and you decide for yourself
who's actually pushing buttons and how
prophecy is going to be fulfilled.
>> But I I do want to say that you and I
both are in agreement that
America is going to embrace a false
version of Christianity that is going to
Yeah. It's going to look like peace,
safety, unity. It's going to look like
the most loving thing, tolerance.
And um we're starting to see that stuff
in the headlines. I've been seeing on my
feed that Trump says he's going to bring
the country back to God and all this
stuff. It sounds great, man. To your
Christian mind, you're just like, "This
is amazing. This is what I want." But um
you have to test everything according to
the word of God.
>> Mikey Mikey, I'm going it's going to
blow your mind what I'm going to be
showing in our next meeting. Ooh,
>> we're going to see this religious
movement that he erected, which I
believe he meant for good. The internal
struggle that has been taking place
already.
>> I will share with you what's happening.
It's getting bad.
>> Yeah,
>> it's getting bad because people are
noticing that a lot of these leaders
that have been handpicked by this man
are not there for the right agenda.
Yeah.
>> Or with the right agenda in mind. They
have their own agenda and it's going to
get worse. We'll be getting to that
hopefully if you invite me back on your
platform.
>> Absolutely, man. I can't wait for part
two.
>> Now, I'm about to I'm about to close
this for today and then we'll we will
revisit for the next time. Is that all
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, now I want you to notice it
says here, let's go back to verse 40.
And at the time of the end shall the
king of the south push at him and the
king of the north shall come against him
like a whirlwind with chariots and with
horsemen and with many ships. Are
Muslims are radical Muslims really
planning to attack Rome? Well, we
already took took care about that. Oh,
took care of that. Um, you know what?
For the sake of time, I'm going to pass
this this one particular clip. Let's get
to this point here and then we'll close
out here. Okay, it says here, "And he
shall enter also into the glor into the
glorious land and many countries shall
be overthrown." Now Mikey, I'll just
pause here real quick because there are
some people unfortunately from our faith
that believe that this terminology
glorious land is talking about America.
Well, you cannot prove that word of God
that that's not that that's referring to
America. I can show you from the word of
God is talking about Palestine or
Jerusalem more.
>> Wow.
>> But it is we're spiritualized in this
way.
>> Yeah. But I can give it to you in a
little context. Okay. But anyways, has
the world turned their eyes back to the
little geographical location of Israel,
Jerusalem today? Oh, most definitely.
>> Yeah. Anti-semitism is, you know,
they're they're making laws against
anti-semitism and all this stuff.
>> But but Mikey, this presentation, this
was over, this is about 10 years ago
that I put this together.
>> Wow.
>> What you're seeing here was not anything
I just came up with today. This was like
10 years ago, brother. Yeah.
>> So I to me at least to me this is what
Daniel 11 is pointing to.
>> Now I want you to notice that in Daniel
11 what it says here. Now Sean's hit
number vers number 665 I mean 45 says
the following. The term glorious
land in Daniel 11:16 and 41 is the same
exact Hebrew word found in Daniel 8:9
which refers to Judea. Remember when I
said Daniel 8 actually goes with Daniel
11 over here it says here talking about
the little horn and out of one of them
came forth a little horn. We know that
it's the papacy
>> which wax exceeding great toward the
south toward the east and toward the
pleasant land. That word pleasant is the
same exact um word for glorious. No one
is going to dispute that's talking about
Judea. So why are we saying now oh no
now it it changes and it means America.
That's not what Daniel referring to
>> Daniel 11 is keeping his eyes fixed.
Remember what's going to be fall upon
thy people, but we it's going to give us
a a better understanding of who his
people was in the last in the last days.
Just a bit. So, glorious land, you have
Jerusalem here. All right. Has the world
turned their backs, their eyes? Oh,
sorry, I'm repeating this. Okay.
Remember um um October 7th, 2023, two
years ago? Remember what happened?
Not necessarily. What happened?
>> Remember Gaza?
>> Israel caught off guard after the
largest and deadliest escalation of
violence in decades. Tonight, rockets
and air strikes continue to rain down on
Israel and Gaza. Now Mikey, what I'm
doing is is pulling back the curtain to
give you some historical um footprint
leading us to our next segment that we
will be taking care of until our day.
You've got to understand this is not
just happening overnight. There's
reasons for all of this. Okay, there's
reasons for all of this.
Israel caught off guard after the
largest and deadliest escalation of
violence in decades. Tonight, rockets
and air strikes continue to rain down on
Israel and Gaza after a day of shock,
death, and destruction.
>> That's the Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu declaring war against
Hamas. Good evening and thank you for
joining us. At dawn local time, Hamas
militants launched an unprecedented and
large-scale surprise attack targeting
dozens of
>> Now, you remember this, right,
>> Mikey? This took place.
>> Okay, it was in the headline. I'm just
forward. Okay.
>> CNN poll, Americans are deeply
sympathetic towards Israelis and see
their military response to a mass Hamas
attacks as justified. And this was back
in 2023. Okay, now we're running through
the course of Israel. Welcome back,
America.
>> Now, listen to this. This is Mark Levin
that he's that he brings on the um this
evangelical, if I'm not mistaken, this
is the clip, John Haggy. Um Pastor
Haggy.
>> Oh, John.
>> Yes. Okay. So, listen to listen to this.
>> Have a dear friend, a great patriot, one
of the greatest friends Israel has.
Pastor John Hegy, founder, chairman of
Christians United for Israel, senior
pastor, Cornerstone Church, St. Antonio,
Texas. You know, pastor, you don't
really need an introduction, but there I
gave you.
>> Now, remember, we're talking about a
couple years ago. We're not talking
about right now today. Okay? So, these
clips are just a little old, but we're
talking about, you know, 23 just what,
three years ago, a one.
>> Get right down to business here.
>> You're a leading evangelical Christian
voice in the United States of America.
You have millions of people who follow
you.
you have a a huge church
and uh my question to you is this
is this war that's taking place against
Israel and the Jews is it a war that all
Americans should be very very concerned
about?
>> Absolutely. America should be concerned
about it. one because
if democracy in the Middle East is
destroyed, it gives all of the enemies
of democracy a capacity to destroy the
democracy in this country. I think
there's something that the American
people need to think about that Iran was
the mastermind behind this this war and
Hamas were the ground troops. Now Mikey,
it's going to get better because I'm
gonna I'm bringing this evangelical on
the scene to help you to understand that
if he's a prominent figure in the
evangelical world world and many people
listen to him, they flock to hear him.
He has an influence upon the evang
evangelical world.
>> And since he's a pastor, they'll they'll
regard what he's saying as true. Yes or
no?
>> Yep. Absolutely.
He's a strong believer. He's a strong
advocate for the Jews today. Now, this
is not talking about, you know, being an
anti-semit. This has nothing to do with
that. I'm giving you what prophet is
trying to tell us.
>> Okay. Now, this is an evang evangelical
voice. Now, I'm going to move forward
because there was more that he wanted to
say, but I really want to get to another
point here. Okay. Does paper
Christianity have any words for what's
taking place in the Middle East? Well,
ruters.com has this to say. Pope urges
am mass to free hostages says Israel has
right to defend to self-defense. Now
this was Pope Francis that said this a
couple years ago. Okay. And I'm just
going to bypass this. Uh here it says
the national Catholic reporter Pope
Francis condemns Hamas terrorism but
expresses concern for Gaza civilians. So
he's trying to play defense if you will
here. And then you have you know um
clips of wars. Now I'm just going to
bypass all this because I want to get to
another point here.
>> All right.
Um, here, let me get over here. Now,
look, look at this point. This is where
we're going to end it at. Okay. Does
paper Christianity really want control
over the Temple Mount in Jerusalem? What
do you think?
>> Yeah, I do.
>> Okay. Look at this headline. This is
back in 2014.
>> Oh, report. Vatican presses for control
of what?
>> Mount Zion.
>> That's not my words. That's their words.
How about this one here? US plan gives
Jerusalem holy sites to who?
>> Vatican.
>> That's 2013. So, has it been working in
darkness? Oh, yes.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Oh, yes. But it doesn't stop there. It
doesn't stop there. Are people I meant
to say wanting to destroy the Dome of
the Rock
to to um place I'm sorry, I had a I had
written this wrong. says here to replace
the Dome of the Rock. To destroy the
Dome of Rock, to build the third temple.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Who's that there that you see there? Who
do you This is an older video, but who
do you think that is there?
>> I actually don't know who that is.
>> You ever heard of um Pete Hex Hexf?
>> I've heard his name.
>> Okay, we'll be talking about him a
little bit more, but check this out.
He's the head of the Pentagon. Okay.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Right.
Jennifer,
>> this was years ago. This was years ago.
Okay, this is not now. What he says now,
but now he's the head of the military
now in terms of, you know, underneath um
Trump. Okay, but check this out.
>> He had a chance to go see the Western
Wall of the temple. Now, the Western
Wall tunnels, uh, so much of the old
city. And as you stand there, you can't
help but behold the miracle before you.
And it got me thinking about another
miracle that I hope all of you don't see
too far away because 1917 was a miracle.
1948 was a miracle. 1967 was a miracle.
2017 the declaration of Jerusalem as the
capital was a miracle. And there's no
reason why the miracle of the
reestablishment of the temple on the
temple mount is not possible.
>> You see that?
>> Yeah.
>> Wow.
They're pointing to Jerusalem and they
are advocating for the taking back of
the Temple Mount. Now, question Mikey,
what's on the Temple Mount today?
>> It is the um Oh, I can't remember the
name of it, but it's that really famous
>> Dome of the Rock, the Islamic Mosque.
Well, where they circle Mecca, right? Is
it Mecca or
>> No, that's is this one is in Jerusalem.
Okay. So the three main holy sites is
Mecca, Medina, and Jerusalem.
>> Okay.
>> One of their holy sites.
>> Yes. And this is the holy site that they
believe that Muhammad had ascended up to
heaven.
>> Wow.
>> Now, if this is their third sacred site,
imagine tampering with that. What do you
think is going to happen with the
Islamic world?
>> War, bro.
>> I'm tell exactly when you hear it echoed
for years.
>> Yeah.
>> And this is what this man is saying. Let
me finish the video.
>> I don't know how it would happen. You
don't know how it would happen, but I
know that it could happen.
>> You see, now this is B. Hex stated in
this several years back
>> today.
>> Well, how about this guy that's a rabbi?
Listen to now. He's a Jewish ra. This is
a leader. This is supposed to be in
terms, if you were to use our terms, a
minister of the gospel, if you Oh, no,
not gospel of the Torah, if you will.
Okay. Listen to what this rabbi says on
how they should be able to take over
that Temple Mount. Check this out.
>> If it was up to me, the last time when
they shot hundreds of missiles, I would
pretend that one missile came from Iran
and shoot it down.
>> Okay. So, what is saying is we'll shoot
one of our own, but we'll blame it on
Iran.
>> Wow.
>> Okay.
You know, then all the Arabs will go
against Iran. It will be the end of the
problems. You make them fight with each
other. This bunch of lunatics.
>> Wow.
>> Never too late. You deal with a bunch of
cowards.
>> Okay. Why? Why would you do that?
I thought we're supposed to be holding
up to the Ten Commandments,
>> right? Keep
>> I should not lie.
But this is what his followers will
listen to.
>> Now, who's you ever heard of Greg Lock?
>> Greg Lock. Yeah,
>> brother. Listen to what this brother had
to say. Check this out about the Temple
Mount.
>> Now, listen. Here's what I think. I told
my wife this last night. This be the
most controversial thing I say, but I'll
be all right. I'll preach in a minute.
>> This was several years ago, too.
>> Oh, really?
>> Yes. I think two years ago. Somebody I
hope get this message to Benjamin Net
and Yahoo
>> two or three years ago
>> that he ought to take care of the rest
of them Yahoos.
>> Now I'm going to tell you what would fix
it right now. By the way, it'd fix it.
It would help usher in what we're
wanting so bad.
>> While they're mowing down the Gaza
Strip,
>> listen to what he says.
>> And letting them terrorists know exactly
what we do with terrorists, which is not
compromise or negotiate.
What they ought to do is evacuate up
there on the hill and get a great big
missile.
>> Listen,
>> and blow that wicked dome of the rock
plum off of the spot where it's standing
right now so we can get that THIRD
TEMPLE REBUILT AND USHER IN THE COMING
OF JESUS.
>> TEAR DOWN THAT BIG DEMONIC MONSTROSITY
THAT SHOULDN'T EVEN BE THERE.
BLOW THE whole thing to kingdom come.
Rebuild that third temple and we'll zip
up out of here in the glory land. Amen.
>> Yes, I said it. Yes, Twitter, enjoy
yourself.
>> They had to blow the whole thing up.
>> Mikey, you hear how they're talking in
the West?
>> Yeah, man.
>> And this is nothing, brother. This is
nothing. You know what's so ironic is
he's talking about blow that demonic
dome up so that we can build a third
temple. You know what's demonic? It's a
temple where you're going to sacrifice
animals because God says the blood of
bulls and goats does not appease him. So
why are they wanting to build an
antirist? Literally an antichrist temple
because you're denying Christ with that
temple.
Now, I want you to notice, Mikey, these
are evangelicals. This is this is not a
Jew himself, right?
>> This is an evangelical
promoting such an action.
And the thing is that we brother,
there's more to the story. Oh, I wish I
had I had more hours, but of course, I
got to cut it. I got to cut short. But I
just But brother, listen. When you see
pictures like this, it tells you a lot.
>> A lot.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Okay. Let's see if Daniel can give us
more clues to know what else people
Christianity will want to do. The Bible
says that he shall stretch forth his
hand upon the countries and the land of
Egypt shall not escape. But he the king
of the north shall have power over the
treasures of gold and of silver and over
all the precious things of Egypt and and
li and the Libyans and the Ethiopian
shall be at his steps.
>> Now remember this is still in the south.
Now the Bible says in Daniel I'm sorry I
don't know why I have here. It's
supposed to be Matthew 24:14.
>> This gospel of the kingdom shall be
preached in all the world for as a
witness unto all nations and then the
end shall come. So the gospel is going
to be spreading throughout the world and
then Jesus is going to come. Well, don't
you think that the Muslims will be
included in this?
>> Yeah.
>> The Bible says Daniel 11:41, "But these
shall escape out of his hand, even Edom
and Moab and the chief children of
Ammon." Now, let me just tackle this and
I promise you we'll close.
Jesus says, "Other sheep I have which
are not of this fold. Them also I must
bring, and they shall hear my voice, and
there should be one fold and one
shepherd, and I know them, and they
what? They follow me."
>> Follow me.
>> Now, my question is, do you think even
within the Muslim race that there's
people that Jesus wants to save?
>> 100%.
>> All of them.
>> I believe that this is applied to them.
Okay. So now let's cover this and then
we'll close. It says here and you look
remember he's looking at a map.
The Davidic kingdom when David was in
rule remember he was conquering nations.
You can read it in 2 Samuel when he took
the throne he got to he got to business.
He started he started conquering the
surrounding nations to make sure that he
stuck his claim to those lands. And we
notice that eventually within his
jurisdiction what do you see to the
right of Jerusalem or Judah? Ammon,
Moab, and Edom.
>> Wow.
>> That was under the kingdom.
>> Now, I want you to notice this was not
the Israelites.
Now, some may say it was kin to them. Of
course, we have Edom and Mo, of course,
and Ammon. You you can read it from um
Lot, of course, what happened to his
descendants and all this other stuff.
But you notice that this is all there
right now. People will argue today,
listen to me very clearly. People will
say, "Well, Ernest, Edom, Moab, and
Ammon don't ever exist again." and or
rather don't exist today and I believe
and I say are you sure they said yeah
Ammon does not exist it doesn't okay so
that was the Davidic kingdom map when
you look today the map of of the
territory remember he's looking at the
territory you still have Ammon there
aman Jordan the capital city of Jordan
ancient Moab and ancient Edom is still
under is is part of that nation if you
So case in point is the following.
When Daniel's looking at the map, he's
looking at the geographical locations of
these places. And those places are most
predominantly occupi occupied by
Muslims.
>> That's what he's seeing. Are you getting
what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. This is what this is what Daniel
is simply um seeing rather the Gabriel's
actually showing him. That's what's
being covered. So let me let me just
finish it off by saying this. Egypt I
believe represents the radicals the
extremist side of Islam and are
destroyed by peopleled Christianity.
When you see Iran acting the way that
they act, you see how they're being
destroyed. That's what I believe is a
representation of Egypt. When you hear
the words or read the words Libyans and
Ethiopians,
I believe that terminology is referring
them to submitting to Rome. In other
words, they're not going to submit their
allegiance in terms of their religion to
Rome. They'll just submit in order to
save their lives.
>> Yeah.
>> However, there's a small group that's
Edom, Moab, and Ammon or Ammon that
follow the lamb of God. These are the
people that God is trying to show Daniel
that there's going to be a small sack
>> that will escape out of his hands. In
other words, that will be able to be
saved. And you I don't know if you ever
heard this a couple years ago and even
till today, there's a lot of people from
that na from those nations out there
from the east if you will that are
having dreams and visions of Issa or
Jesus as we call him. They're having
visions of Jesus appearing to them and
they are they are literally letting go
of their previous religion or their
beliefs and now flocking to
Christianity.
>> That's why Christianity is starting to
emerge because a lot of people being
saved by way of visions and dreams. Um
brother
>> I have heard that.
>> Now go ahead. Go ahead. I was just going
to say I have heard that somebody in the
comment said that um we are not told to
pray for Babylon but Jesus did say pray
for your enemies.
>> You were not pray again you know brother
I mean you know I appreciate what the
com what the commentator is I mean what
that person is commentating but you know
I I'm sorry I'm of the belief that we're
to pray like you said the Bible says
love your enemies.
>> Yeah. Pray for those who persecute you.
So I mean how am I not to I mean then
who's my enemy then?
>> Right?
>> Is it talking about just somebody church
>> when when when Jesus when Jesus was
speaking of the Romans when they slap
you on one side of the cheek
>> when they or make you walk walk a mile
or you're to walk tween. He was talking
>> he's talking about the enemies.
>> Jesus himself on the cross. Father
forgive them. They know not what they
do.
>> They know not what they do. He forgives
them and put on the cross.
>> Steven being stoned to death. let not
this sin fall upon them. These are
people who are killing them. They're
praying for them.
>> Isn't that something?
>> So, I you know, I I strongly disagree
with what that person put in the
comments. I believe that we're supposed
to pray for these very people.
>> Amen.
>> Um you know, we again remember our
condition. Some of us, we talk that way,
but yet we're the worst of sinners.
>> Yeah. the fact that Jesus Christ wants
to save us. But when we really look and
analyze our own characters, we are so so
wretched and blind,
but Jesus came down from heaven, Mikey,
to save you and I
>> and you know our past.
>> Yeah.
>> So we're, you know, we we don't deserve
to be saved, but because of Christ's
love for us, that's why we have an
opportunity to join him in the kingdom
of heaven. Would you agree with that?
>> Amen. 100%, bro.
you know, so you know, I know this was a
long draw out um um um presentation, but
brother, I had to give it to you in this
way. Um because of the fact that um
um is it's like I said, it's a lot of
history to this to this one subject, you
know.
>> Yeah, man. You you've done your
homework, and I'm so glad that you did
present this because I learned a lot. I
I didn't know the answer to this when
people would ask who's the king of the
south, who's the king of the north. And
what you show me is 100% biblical,
biblical, historical, geographical. I
believe it the way you presented it
unless somebody can show me otherwise.
Um this is this is the perfect
understanding right here.
>> Yeah. So, and you know, and brother,
again, I Mikey,
straight up, man, I know that this is
not going to be an easy pill for us to
swallow. I get it. I didn't want to
swallow it at first because I believed
it a certain way. But the more that I
started to study this, I said, "Nah,
Lord, I see what you're pointing me to."
But again, everybody's still free to
believe what they want to be. I mean,
want want to believe.
>> I'm not forcing this down on anybody's
throat. Please don't force it down on my
throat either. You follow what I'm
saying? And all you got to do is study
for yourselves. If you feel that I'm
lying, hey, submit to me something that
that's contrary to that, but give me the
evidence. Don't don't don't tell me that
I'm wrong. Show me that I'm wrong. Does
that make sense?
>> Amen. Yeah.
>> So, brother Mike, I appreciate you
allowing me to um present this um on on
your platform. And of course, until we
meet again, brother, you know, we're
going to get deeper into the roots of
it.
>> Amen. Brother, thank you so much for
coming on here sharing this. There was a
lot of good comments. Actually, the
majority of the comments coming in are
people that are either agree or they're
seeing it for the first time and
believing it. Only a few that disagreed.
And brother, I just can't thank you
enough for coming on. I'm looking
forward to part two. If anybody here
wants to see more, wants to know who you
are, how can they find you, any of your
content, do you have anything out there?
>> No, I don't have I'm actually building
my platform. I've been building it for
the past 10 years, absolutely, but I've
been so busy, brother. But they can
invite you to speak.
>> Yeah, they can invite me to speak if
they want to. I can give my number if
you would like. My number is 58-2718660.
Again, it's 58-271-8660.
My name is Ernest Rosa. And then of
course we can try to we can you can um
you if you want to you can contact me
and then we can try to make some
appointments so that I can do just that.
>> And you do a a myriad of things. What
else do you do?
I do just name it.
>> I mean, you give presentations on
prophecy, marriage counseling, marriage
seminars.
>> Yes. Um, talk about evangelism. As a
matter of fact, I'm about to do some
more evangelism, church training,
whatever the case. I just did I was in
Hawaii for over a month training a
church and training a church from the
from the roots, if you will. Um,
training the officers to know their
offices. And then of course um from
there um I also did um evangelism
and we dealt with the first one that
dealt with in-house evangelism. How to
know rather I was trying to teach them
how to evangelize.
>> What's the purpose of evangelism?
>> We just think it's taking out tracks and
just inviting people to the church. No,
that's that's more heart training behind
behind the curtain. And then afterwards
we I did a seminar on marriage which
actually that whole church they I don't
think it was ever filled to that
capacity
>> when I gave that seminar it was a
five-part seminar
>> and it's an unconventional seminar
unconventional seminar matter of fact I
do have a website for that to be honest
with you um it's called
marriedtillupart.com
married m a r m a m a r r i e d till t i
l U the letter U part A p a r t.com.
>> You can find me on that website and you
can email me through that website as
well or you can contact me if you want
me to do a five-part seminar. And the
basics um of those I have two types of
marriage seminars on that website that
um if you need to, you know, they want
to call me to to um present at their
church, we can we can work with that.
But that's the one that I do have. I
forgot about that one. I do have that
one. Working to try to get another
official website for my main ministry.
>> Awesome.
>> Um so that I can be contacted through
that.
>> Yeah. I heard your marriage seminars,
man. It was really it was very
insightful, helpful, and even comical
sometimes. And it was really good, man.
>> Yeah. So
>> that you know, that's the one that it
gets a lot of people going because, you
know, I touch on I touch on points,
brother Mikey, that people don't want to
touch on. And I touch I touch on those
points in the church.
>> We need to hear it, brother. Because I
tell people, if you don't hear it in the
church, you're going to get it on
YouTube. You're going to get it from the
streets. And you're going to get it the
way that the devil wants you to hear it.
I think it's time for us to hear the way
that God intended us to hear it. And we
treat taboo almost. Even when it comes
to the to sexual intercourse, things of
that nature, we need to hear about it.
That's
>> one of the reasons why there's a decline
in marriages. Yeah.
>> Just with that alone.
>> You know what I'm saying? So, we touch
on many points, the communication and
things of that nature and and and then
the initial course that I that I that I
give um has to deal with um and I try to
include everybody. Those that are
contemplating marriage, those that are
dating, those that are divorced,
everybody and anybody is um included.
I love it, brother. Well, thank you so
much for coming on, man. This was
definitely a divine appointment and I
know it blessed many people. There was
at least 150 people in here, which is a
a good live for us. So, if you guys were
blessed by this live stream, please give
it a thumbs up. Really helps get this
video out into the algorithm so more
people can see it. This is very
important stuff for us to know in these
last days because we need to know our
enemy. We need to know prophecy. We need
to know what's coming because we need to
be prepared for this very soon deception
that's coming upon the world like an
overwhelming surprise. And we cannot
fall for the Antichrist system. We have
to be prepared for what's coming after
that which is Christ and his glory. And
I pray every day that that we are ready
that we will not fall for these
deceptions that we will have discernment
from Christ. And if you want to support
this ministry, you can do so by going to
candidruth.org. We got Cash App,
Vinmozelle, PayPal. We even got Patreon.
We got a lot of cool t-shirts that we
get about $5 uh per sale on shirts,
mugs, uh stickers, whatever you want to
get on there. that really helps support
this ministry. And if you guys have been
giving to this ministry, we love you. We
thank you. We cannot do this without
you. We see you and we try to we try to
respond to everybody out there, but
certain platforms like Zel and Cash App
won't let us respond, but we do see you
and we love you and we thank you so
much. We cannot do this without you. And
we actually have a fundraiser for this
new brochure that's going to be coming
out. We're going to get 20,000 plus
printed as soon as we get the money uh
raised for that. There'll be a link in
the description. That is going to be on
zephy.com and I'm going to show you an
advertisement for that right now. Until
next time, we'll see you next time on
Candid Truth. If you guys didn't know,
Trump just said that he's about to
disclose UFOs.
>> President Trump announced Thursday
evening that he would be directing
relevant agencies to release files on
aliens and UFOs. knowing what we know as
Bible believing Christians that this is
Satan's final masquerade. There are
millions of people out there who have no
idea what's coming. All they know is
that the military is telling them that
aliens are real and they're here and
they're among us.
>> Biologics came with some of these
recoveries.
>> Were they I guess human or non-human
biologics?
>> Non-human. And that was the assessment
of people uh with direct knowledge on
the program I talked to.
>> We are going to get 20,000 of these
printed and hopefully we'll get more.
This says top secret UFO disclosure in
Bible prophecy. It's analog, so you
don't need the internet or electricity,
and you can put it right in somebody's
hands. And it's concise and
straightforward and gets right to the
point. Printing isn't cheap, but we got
a great deal on these prints from a
personal friend of mine in California.
So, with your help, we can get 20,000 or
more of these printed if you just click
on the donation link below to help us
expose the lies before it's too late.